[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour le
moment fort de la semaine au sénat les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement à
commence dans une rac 1 0 précisé on
vous les fait vivre cette semaine avec
quentin qu'elle met dans l'hémicycle du
sénat
bonjour quentin alors quelles vont être
les temps forts de cette séance avait
bien on s'attend à un temps forts
notamment avec ces trois questions
consacré aux propos de claire et dont la
défenseure des droits sur des zones sans
contrôle d'identité
cette phrase fait beaucoup réagir
notamment la droite au sénat on va
suivre aussi des questions sur la
situation des étudiants sur leur
détresse mais donc voyez c'est original
cette semaine tamas et peu de questions
sur la crise sanitaire et notamment sur
la vaccination
et voilà les semaines se suivent et ne
se ressemblent pas forcément avec nous
également
alexandre pouchard celle des conférences
pour toutes les réactions des ministres
des sénateurs alexandre alors un aperçu
de votre programme
bonjour tam et bien je serai notamment
avec le ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer pourparlers a dit slam
au gauchisme alors que le gouvernement a
lancé une enquête sur l'influencé de ce
pseudo courant de pensée au sein de
l'université
merci à tout à l'heure alexandre et
enfin nous sommes avec notre streamer
politique jean maciek et anime sa propre
émission sur twitch autour des questions
gouvernement est gentil va suivre tout
ça donc avec ta communauté véritable on
va suivre ça et j'ai hâte de voir les
questions que nous ont préparé les
sénateurs et des sénatrices je pense
qu'on va beaucoup parler de vote par
correspondance aujourd'hui par
anticipation plus tôt oui effectivement
on va en parler déjà dans une demi-heure
notre face à face avec est la sénatrice
union centriste valérie létard et le
sénateur socialiste éric kerrouche le
gouvernement veut autoriser le vote par
anticipation pour la présidentielle
objectif faire baisser l'abstention mais
la méthode passe mal au sénat car pour
introduire cette mesure le gouvernement
a choisi de déposer un amendement de
dernière minute la droite sénatoriale
dénoncent déjà des magouilles
politiciennes on en débat à 14h30
[Musique]
mais d'abord c'est l'heure d'un premier
bilan pour le ségur de la santé les
mesures engagées depuis cet été en
faveur de l'hôpital sont elles à la
hauteur on en débat avec florence
lassarade bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains de la gironde
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
sociales et je précise que vous êtes
également médecin sur ce plateau face à
vous et n'a brillé bonjour je vous êtes
délégué général de la fédération
hospitalière de france et enfin nous
sommes dans vision avec christophe
prudhomme bonjour vous êtes médecin
urgentiste les porte-parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france et enfin nous sommes avec
daniel chassa sénateurs les indépendants
de la corrèze vice président de la
commission des affaires sociales et vous
est également médecin de profession
alors nous sommes six mois après le
ségur de la santé un an après le début
de la pandémie
qu'est ce qui a changé dans notre
système de santé depuis le début de
cette crise le gouvernement a débloqué
plusieurs milliards l'été dernier mais
suffisant pour régler la situation
alarmante de l'hôpital on en débat après
le point sur la situation aurélien
romano le ségur de la santé a été signée
il ya près de sept mois pourtant de
nombreuses mesures promises n'ont pas
encore été mis en place
seule l'une des mesures emblématiques la
revalorisation des salaires a bien été
financée et les personnels du secteur
public ont vu leur salaire augmenter de
près de 183 euros
les autres mesures sont toujours en
attente sur les douze mille lits de
réanimation premier à peine la moitié
est actif faute de personnels formés sur
la tarification à l'acte les syndicats
dénoncent un manque d'avancées enfin les
19 milliards d'investissements annoncés
ne sont pas encore votée on n'a pas vu
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
après les prochaines lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale n'arriveront
qu'en septembre de cette année espérons
qu'on verra tous et tous ces projets à
l'intérieur
toutes ces mesures sont en attente souad
ordonnance qui doivent arriver en mars
soit de la prochaine loi de finances des
délais beaucoup trop long en pleine
crise sanitaire selon les syndicats même
ceux qui ont signé l'accord comme la
cfdt déplore des décrets qui tendent à
dénaturer ce qui a été signé
la cgtl non signataires dénoncent des
démissions plus nombreuses que des
embauches et des départs à la retraite
remplacez 15000 recrutements nets
étaient pourtant au programme du ségur
de la santé six mois après le choc
d'attractivité n'a donc pas encore eu
lieu
alors la crise de l'hôpital ne date pas
de la pandémie il ya déjà plus d'un an
on se rappelle du cri d'alarmé qui avait
été poussé par les personnels
hospitaliers il y avait déjà eu des
grèves des manifestations
un an après alors que notre système de
santé a été en première ligne face à la
crise sanitaire
où en est on christophe prudhomme est ce
que pour vous aujourd'hui il ya du mieux
à goûter non face à la crise aujourd'hui
nous manquons de personnel de lille il
est clair que les 183 euros
troyer à une partie des personnels mais
voyez qu'il ya des grèves tous les jours
parce qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle les
excuses du ségur donc 783 euros sont
toujours bons à prendre mais sont
présentes sat ce qu'il faudrait pour que
les soignants en france rejoigne la
moyenne de rémunération des pays de la
cedeao et puis surtout le problème qui
se pose c'est rien n'a été fait au
niveau du personnel et des lits et si
nous sommes aujourd'hui en difficulté il
ya une explosion du nombre de malades
nous avons trois mille un petit peu
moins de 3500 malades en réanimation et
rien n'a été fait pour augmenter ce
nombre de lits si l'argument du manque
de personnel pourraient s'entendre il ya
un an
pourquoi n'avoir pas répondu à la
demande augmenter le nombre d'un terne
donc spécialisé en réanimation il aurait
pu prendre leur poste au mois de
novembre
pourquoi n'at-on pas former des aides
soignantes il faut un an pour former les
expériences en particulier pour les et
palais pour un certain nombre de
services et en ce qui concerne les
infirmières pourquoi l'at-on pas garder
les infirmières qui s'était porté
volontaire pour armer les animations
printemps dernier quand quelques restes
et on aurait pu compléter leur formation
et on serait pas en situation
aujourd'hui d'être obligé de déclencher
le plan blanc et de déprogrammer les
patients ce qui a des conséquences sur
la santé de la population qui n'est pas
atteinte
9 donc on est dans une situation qui est
aujourd'hui un peu changé par rapport à
mars et avril dernier et du juste une
dernière intérieur éléments on parle de
2 milliards oui 8 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui pas ce qui
a été engagé pour le secteur de la santé
quand je compare ça au seul bénéfice de
sanofi pour l'an dernier 12 milliards
voyez qu'on est loin du compte
et oui et pourtant et n'a brillé des
budgets ont été débloqués on se rappelle
de ce qui avait été actée par le ségur
de la santé à l'époque on nous avait
parlé de 19 milliards d'investissements
dans le système de santé 8,2 milliards
par an pour revaloriser les métiers
15000 recrutement dans l'hôpital public
on nous avait dit également qu on allait
accélérer la sortie de la t2a c'est à
dire la tarification à l'acte pour
privilégier la qualité des soins mais on
n'entend christophe prudhomme il estime
que rien n'est allé suffisamment vite et
puis surtout peut-être que ça faisait
suite à une période où on avait eu des
économies d'année en année une padoue
vraiment l'hôpital avait été mis au
régime sec
oui tout à fait vous avez tous les deux
raison de rappeler un certain nombre
d'éléments mais peut-être pour mémoire
rappeler pourquoi ce secteur de la santé
ce ségur de la santé la crise sanitaire
a révélé la prise de conscience de tout
à chacun de la nécessité de renforcer
l'hôpital public et ses équipes ainsi
que ses investissements car comme vous
l'avez dit très justement
l'investissement dans les hôpitaux
publics a chuté on pour arriver à un
taux historiquement bas jamais connu de
ces vingt dernières années
capacité d'investir inférieur à 4% et
que par ailleurs ces équipes
hospitalières et médico social devaient
être valorisé et reconnu à la hauteur de
leur utilité sociale et de leur
engagement dans le service public
donc on a à peine combler un retard
finalement avec ses annonces mais est ce
qu'on avait fait suffisamment pour
l'avenir eh oui très bonne question vous
avez tout à fait raison
il s'agissait là d'un plan de rattrapage
sur deux points urgents qui sont les
revalorisations salariales et deuxième
point la relance de l'investissement
public et pour répondre à votre dernière
question concernant les investissements
et la forme de financements
c'est vrai que ça tarde on tarde à voir
la relance de l'investissement public on
nous
on sait la reprise de la dette mais il
faut absolument que ça constitue une
vraie relance de l'investissement à
l'hôpital public comme dans le champ
médico-social public
florence lassarade donc on vient de le
dire cette crise sanitaire a permis de
faire la lumière sur toutes les
difficultés de l'hôpital à ce que la
réponse budgétaire mais aussi la réforme
de la gouvernance actée par le ségur et
pour vous à la hauteur cette réforme de
la gouvernance allait notamment et bien
elle fait l'objet d'un texte qui est
débattu aujourd'hui au sénat non moi je
n'avais pas attendu la crise kovy pour
pour dire que les soignants devraient
être des divas puisque on a vraiment
besoin dans son est rendu compte mais en
fait ce sont des esclaves
on a juste actuellement rattrapé
quelques quelques inégalités quelques
injustices mais malgré tout on en crée
d'autres en particulier
moi j'ai été en contact avec unis cancer
on se rend compte que les praticiens ne
peuvent pas avoir les mêmes émoluments
que leurs collègues hospitaliers nuit
qualifée pour et puis malgré tout la
santé c'est une ses global madame busin
avait parlé de l'exercice mixte libéral
hôpital on en entend plus parler
on avait parlé beaucoup d'infirmiers de
pratiques avancées quand on parle des
hôpitaux psychiatriques qui sont
complètement sinistré il n'y a plus
d'école d'affirmer psychiatrique dont ce
sont les jeunes infirmiers qu'on envoie
au charbon alors qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément l'expérience je pense qu'on
est vraiment loin du compte dernière
chose quand on parle de médecine il faut
pas il faut penser et
et dessous d'autres soignants il faut
penser études études longues
or on a instauré la suppression du
numerus clausus mais en fait à la sortie
n'y aura pas plus d'étudiants qui
puissent faire leurs études par manque
de formateurs par manque de structures
par manque de moyens il n'y a pas la
règle les moyens sont pas à son port en
amener pas en amont du du problème et
encore une fois on vient comme on a fait
pour la crise des urgences autrefois
boucher des trous mais on anticipe
absolument pas la suite de toute façon
on le voit bien pour le coc vide il n'ya
pas d'anticipation et on est toujours
dans l'inconnu et dans l'immédiateté
on va rappeler les ambitions du ségur au
niveau non budgétaires il y avait l'idée
de lutter contre le recours abusif à
l'intérim médicale l'idée de mieux
associer le personnel médical à la
gestion de l'établissement
celle de forme est plus de soignants
dans les filières paramédicales ou
encore l'idée de donner aux territoires
les leviers de l'investissement santé
daniel chassaing le débat le sénat débat
cet après midi je le disais d'une
proposition de loi de la république en
marche qui traduit ces aspects non
budgétaires du seigneur de la santé et
on l'a entendu il ya quand même beaucoup
de sénateurs qui sont très dubitatifs
notamment dans là dans la majorité
est ce que c'est votre cas oui monsieur
mouche audrey tout d'abord féliciter les
soignants qui ont fait un travail
considérable aussi bien l'hôpital que
dans les ehpad
je voudrais aussi indiqué que l'un le
projet de loi qui nous arrive cet après
midi bien sûr il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
financement le financement ou l'avait
rappelé ça a été quand même important un
rattrapage effectivement puisqu'il n'y a
rien qui avait été fait le puil 2012
alors là c'est cette loi qui nous arrive
ça permet de mettre en place si vous
voulez des précisions des
simplifications après le ségur de la
santé je crois que
il faut le mettre en place il ya des
avancées
quand même avec les femmes avec les
possibilités de revalorisation des chefs
de service de la serbe qui qui qui sera
beaucoup mieux prises en compte
je pense aussi que ce qu'il faut et qui
n'est pas bien sûr dans la dans la loi
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure c'est
la revalorisation parce qu'il ya eu un
rattrapage je pense qu'il faut en tenir
compte et le saluer
mais il faudra une revalorisation
notamment pour les praticiens vous savez
que vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
lutte contre l'intérim
mais la lutte contre l'intérim alors on
peut mettre des sanctions mais attends
attendait le lait les directeurs
d'hôpitaux ceux qui veulent prouver que
les soins puisse se faire donc sont
obligés d'aller vers l'intérim et donc
pour pâques et d'intérim
eh bien il faut le revaloriser davantage
les gardes qui sont qui sont très basses
alors il ya un certain nombre de choses
c'est pas pour ça que il faut jeter
cette proposition de loi qui arrive qui
apporte quelques avancées mais il faudra
que effectivement les amendements du
sénat soit écoutée et qu'au prochain
budget pds et bières on puisse mettre en
place un certain nombre de choses
supplémentaires voilà faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain on se donne
rendez vous au budget de la sécurité
sociale
autre point de vue on va tout de suite
rejoindre alexandre poussard salle des
conférences vous êtes avec la sénatrice
communiste cathy apourceau poly elle
aussi pour une réaction
mais autour de cette situation
aujourd'hui de l'hôpital
wikia pour ce pôle y est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement va tenir les
promesses du ségur de la santé à savoir
améliorer les conditions de travail des
soignants
alors le ségur de la santé pour moi
n'est pas satisfaisant il ya évidemment
ce que je dis mais c'est aussi ce que
nous disent chaque jour les personnels
de santé que nous rencontrons
le compte n'y est pas c'est ce qu'ils
nous disent le compte n'y est pas sur
les augmentations de salaires
le compte n'y est pas sur les fermetures
de services et de lit que nous
rencontrons encore malheureusement avec
cette pandémie
tout aurait dû être stoppé une journée
ont dû mettre les choses sur la table
nous aurions dû répondre aux
revendications et des personnels
soignants et ça n'a pas été fait le
gouvernement n'est vraiment pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'il fallait faire pour
les personnels soignants et paramédicaux
est-ce qu'il ya aussi un problème
d'attractivité de ces métier de soignant
à l'hôpital comment on fait pour les
rendre plus attractifs oui il y a
évidemment je vous le dit fort bien un
problème d'attractivité parce que les
salles et les soignants ne sont pas
payés comme il le faudrait il y à
aujourd'hui et nous le regrettons tous
190000 soignants qui sont diplômés et
qu'ils ne sont pas et qui ne travaillent
plus dans le secteur de la santé lorsque
l'on est soignants on a fait ce métier
par passion parce qu'on voulait aider et
aujourd'hui ces gens sont dehors
pourquoi ne redevienne t-il pas à
l'hôpital eh bien ils ne reviennent pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui hôpital et signe de
souffrance au travail de revalorisation
salariale qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
je rappelle quand même qu'il ya 180 3
euros qui ont été octroyés mais pas à
tous les personnels 1 tous les
personnels n'ont pas eu cette
revalorisation salariale
et pour rappel les soignants demander
une augmentation de salaire de 300 euros
et donc évidemment il n'ya pas
d'attractivité parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de souffrance au travail aujourd'hui
alors qu'est ce que vont proposer les
sénateurs communistes cet après-midi
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
loi c ur de la santé alors nous
proposons de revoir les choses pour
repondre nous proposons de remettre les
choses sur la table il faut absolument
associer plus que jamais les acteurs de
terrain il faut associer les élus locaux
décision il faut associer les acteurs de
terrain il faut associer les jeunes qui
font des études de médecine et nous
proposons donc de revoir les choses et
de regarder par région et par
département les besoins de santé et dans
les hôpitaux publics et en médecine de
ville parce que la médecine de ville
souffre également tinrent mettre tout
sur la table
merci merci beaucoup cathy apourceau
poly d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci à l'occe alexandre en tout cas est
bien le mécontentement des personnels de
santé continue de fait les grèves se
poursuivent à christophe prudemment
parlais tout à l'heure malgré le secteur
de la santé même à cause du secteur de
la santé les grilles de salaires vont
accélérer les carrières des nouveaux
médecins entends ton mais pas celle de
ceux déjà en poste
il ya des secteurs qui estiment avoir
été complètement oubliés comme le
secteur médico-social et dimanche
derniers ainsi devant le ministère de la
santé dans les soignants manifestaient
écouter et l'autre vrai problème c'est
que nous on est tous des soignants ici
et normalement on devrait pas passer
notre temps où nous dimanche matin à
protester pour juste la chose de base
l'hôpital public dans ce pays est une
des seules institutions qui fait
consensus
ce gouvernement n'a pas du tout de
mandat politique pour le mettre à bas et
ça va lui coûter très cher politiquement
s'ils ne sont pas l'hôpital public
christophe prudhomme vous êtes d'accord
avec cela il faut encore aujourd'hui
sauver l'hôpital public on a pris
finalement quoi un canadair pour pour
contenir l'incendié mais il ya toujours
le fait à l'hôpital en le chauffant à
l'hôpital moi je suis catastrophé j'ai
lu le projet de loi ça fait assez c'est
assez lamentable ce projet de loi afin
non mais ce sont des mesures
la seule mesure qui est à peu près
intéressante c'est celle qui concerne
les sages-femmes enfin dans un projet de
loi qu'il y est uniquement l'extension
la prescription chez les sages femmes
face à la crise que connaît l'hôpital
c'est quand même lamentable
et puis l'autre élément c'est la
duplicité les gens qui nous gouvernent
monsieur vers ans messieurs verrons nous
manque aujourd'hui les plans de
restructuration hospitaliers sont à
l'ordre du jour dans mon établissement
l'assistance-publique-hôpitaux paille le
plus grand hôpital d'europe
eh bien on continue à fermer des lits à
restructurer le directeur général martin
une crise valide et signe des documents
pour construire un hôpital dans le nord
de paris qui va se traduire par la
fermeture de deux autres établissements
bichat et beaujon et la suppression de
plus de 300 lits dans une zone j'exerce
qu'elle a sense année où nous manquons
dramatiquement de lit donc entre le
discours les annonces du gouvernement et
la réalité sur le terrain
il ya un grand écart qui aujourd'hui
nous scandalise et nous met vraiment en
colère c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous savez j'étais devant le ministère
la santé dimanche c'était assez
symbolique pour cris notamment de
l'hôpital visiblement ce gouvernement
d'après l'amour de l'hôpital un service
public qui est essentielle pour la
population et que la population jugent
comme essentielle effectivement je pense
que le retour de bâton pour ce
gouvernement risque d'être
catastrophique si effectivement il nous
entend pas s que l'autre particularité
de la période c'est ya aucun dialogue
social aucun dialogue social avec
monsieur véran les portes sont closes
tout est décidé avant d'entrer en
réunion n'a aucune possibilité de
discussion et ça c'est aussi
particulièrement irritant senna bré y
est ce qu'il ya un grand écart donc
entre ce que nous dit le gouvernement
toutes ces annonces un d'amour à l'égard
du personnel hospitalier à l'égard des
médecins et ce qui se passe sur place
christophe prudhomme nous dit eh ben les
restes récupération ils sont toujours au
rendez-vous à sont toujours là non je
crois qu'il faut quand même dire que
tout le monde a conscience et et le
gouvernement premier lieu que l'hôpital
public c'est le premier bouclier
sanitaire de la nation qu'on le veuille
ou non dans cette crise il l'a démontré
ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est qu'on
réglera pas le problème de l'hôpital
public sans s'attaquer au reste d'abord
d'une part il faut sanctuariser les
moyens qui sont dédiés à l'hôpital
public
or c'est vrai que dans le cas des
revalorisations qu'elle soit salariale
ou de la relance de l'investissement
on a vu le gâteau dû partager avec
d'autres acteurs donc là on s'inquiète
effectif va dire c'est à dire que la
relance de l'investissement ne concerne
pas que l'hôpital public ni les
structures médico sociales publiques
elle concerne aussi les autres acteurs
et je rappelle qu'à l'hôpital public
nous n'avons aucune autre marche de
financement nous n'avons pas de capitaux
et nous n'avons pas non pus possibilités
de recours à des essais y par exemple
donc c'est vrai que devoir annoncer que
y compris les mesures salariales et les
mesures dédiées à la relance de la
investissements ne sont pas sanctuariser
pour l'hôpital public ça c'est un
premier fait le deuxième est qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que les mesures en
matière de simplification de la
gouvernance et du pilotage de notre
système de santé
les mesures en matière de financement de
notre système de santé pour avoir un
financement qui ne soit pas comptable
mais qui prennent en compte les parcours
de soins et qui prenne en compte les
enjeux de santé publique tarde à venir
et en plus nous nous avons à déplorer le
report de la réforme du financement de
la psychiatrie et des soins de suite et
enfin pardonnez moi le dernier point
c'est qu'il faut alléger la pression
aussi sur l'hôpital allégé l'arrivée aux
urgences à l'hôpital
est ce qu a mis en évidence cette crise
qu'il fallait mieux organiser l'offre
sur les territoires il faut donner sa
vraie place à la médecine de ville et
aux professionnels de villes qui sont la
première ligne en termes d'offre de
soins vous êtes d'accord avec cela
florence lassarade échoué meilleure
coordination public-privé médecine de
ville hôpital et est-ce que c'est au
rendez vous à ce que fait prévu dans la
proposition de loi qui est débattue cet
après midi non je le disais tout à
l'heure en
on ne favorise pas l'exercice mixte par
exemple moi qui suis pédiatre j'ai
exercé toute ma carrière moitié
l'hôpital moitié en libéral et j'ai ma
force du poignet créer ce poste
finalement mai mais je suis une
exception
or on est on est le même médecin partout
quand on a quand on a envie de soigner
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans sa propre
structure que quand on travaille
différemment notre hôpital les médecins
et les soignants ils ont envie de faire
leur métier c'est tout ils n'ont pas
envie en cm d'écouté pendant des heures
dire qu'il pleut dans l'hôpital que les
bâtiments ne sont pas à la hauteur et
que leur salaire va dépendre du budget
qui va être investi dans les murs là
aussi il faudrait quand même se poser
peut-être la question de savoir pourquoi
on ne fonctionne pas comme dans
l'éducation nationale les murs d'un côté
le fonctionnement de l'homme partout les
communes fonctionnent comme ça enfin on
a tous conscience que le coeur de métier
on peut pas l'exercer comme on aime et
c'est cette hémorragie de personnel
hospitalier qui quittent l'hôpital suite
peut-être à cette crise mais ça a été la
goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
le problème c'est qu'on forme je reviens
à la formation d'aidés soignants qui ne
seront pas soignants ils vont ouvrir des
chambres d'hôtes ils vont faire tout
autre tout autre métier parce que le
parce que l'exercice les auras dégouté
de leur vocation première qui lui
soigner daniel chassaing c'est ça aussi
eu l'une des priorités redonner de
l'attractivité aux professions
hospitalières publiques donner envie aux
personnes qui font des études de
médecine de rester médecin tout au long
de leur carrière
tout à fait donc moi je je nuancerais
quand même ce qui a été dit je pense que
ce qui a été apportée déjà et quand même
considérable
il faut l'améliorer dans la proposition
de loi que nous avons cette après midi
on a la création de possibilités d'accès
aux soins non programmés
ça ça me paraît très important il faut
que dans des territoires où il y à peine
hôpitaux notamment rurales et bien il
faut que les communautés
professionnelles territoire de santé
puissent réaliser cela avec
les maisons de santé je voudrais dire
qu'il ya eu quand même des progrès avec
notamment les six à qui nous amène à du
travail avec les pharmaciens avec les
infirmières mais le gros problème c'est
qu'on a des jeunes qui ne veulent pas
s'installer en rural ou en dehors des
villes
donc c'est ça le gros problème en fait
alors il ya le problème de l'hôpital ça
a été bien indiqués il faut revaloriser
les salaires des soignants de tous les
soignants mais aussi on va avoir des
alcooliques bien sûr qui n'arrange pas
les choses qui complique les choses
partout à l'hôpital et en ehpad mais on
a un gros problème
le numerus clausus bien sûr a été enlevé
je pense qu'il faudra former davantage
en impliquant peut-être les hôpitaux
périphériques pour les stages et je
pense que c'est par ce biais qu'on
arrivera en revalorisant je répète bien
je suis d'accord on arrivera à redonner
et bien à l'hôpital public ce qu'il faut
pour que la france soit bien dotée pour
les choix vous le dites en tout cas la
pandémie est toujours là elles risquent
peut-être même de s'aggraver avec
l'augmentation des variants et pendant
ce temps là et bien certains sujets
n'ont pas bougé notamment celui du
nombre de lits en réanimation toujours
lors de la réunion de cette
manifestation dimanche vous propose
d'écouter patrick peloux qui faisait
partie des manifestants
manque de lits de réanimation médicale
en france et en fait depuis le début de
la crise ils en ont pas ouvert 1 et le
concept qu'ils ont développés qui est un
conte concept en fait de deux de
flexibilité du système en disant on va
faire des réanimations éphémère s'est
déplacé le problème et c'est oublier les
autres malades
florence lassarade on nous dit on monte
toujours de lits de réanimation dans le
contexte actuel est ce que ça vous
paraît normal on prévoit notamment
toutes ces restrictions sanitaires aussi
en fonction du taux de remplissage des
unités de ré
mation donc on se dit que il paraîtrait
logique et nécessaire d'augmenter de
façon pérenne au moins le nombre de lits
pendant cette crise mais comme médecin
hospitalier on a toute ma carrière j'ai
vu se succéder des directeurs
l'avancement directeur était fonction du
nombre de lits qu'il ferme et non pas
ceux faut pas se voiler la face
donc c'est toujours un lance de la
nation doit quand même changer le
logiciel or olivier ferrand avait
annoncé moi je me souviens très bien du
chiffre de 14 mille lits de réanimation
et on n'est passé que pour quelle raison
est ce que le pays est moitié confiné
couvre-feu etc
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas la capacité de
soigner les malades y a pas suffisamment
de lits donc c'est le serpent qui se
mord la queue mais annoncé 14 min quand
on est capable d'en n'ouvrir maximum
dans l'est s'est ouvert maximum 5000
trimballer les gens dans des trains pour
montrer qu'on sait transporter en france
c'est vrai kaunas est expertisé
transports mais au lieu d'ouvrir des
lits sur place ça paraît complètement
aberrant c'est vrai qu'on a on a une
déception mais ces effets d'annoncé il y
compris sur le vaccin
on en est là en annonce des chiffres et
on n'est pas du tout à ce qui avait été
annoncé mais on n'est pas du tout aux
quatorze mille lits de l'animation
jeunes abriel oui et puis ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça quand même parce
qu'on voit bien déjà dans la prise en
charge de cette deuxième vague et ce
plateau au qui perdure c'est pas tant
les lits de réanimation c'est aussi les
lits de médecine parce qu'on a fait des
progrès sur la prise en charge
donc en fait ce qu'il faut absolument
c'est lent changer la logique c'est à
dire que quand on pense capacitaire
c'était nombre de lits on le pense pas
sur la logique économique induite par
l'ondam on la pense sur les enjeux de
santé publique d'un territoire de santé
données sur un territoire si vous avez
une population âgée plus importante si
vous avez une population précaire plus
importante
si vous avez une pub une population
polypathologiques plus importante
vous devez adapter l'offre de lits au
regard de cela et a par ailleurs je
rappelle qu'on n'ouvre pas délivré à
d'un claquement de doigts non plus ça
nécessite du des professionnels formés
et dûment formés christophe prudhomme ya
une circulaire un qui est sorti ce
week-end qui demande aux hôpitaux de se
préparer à l'arrivée du variant de
prévoir une organisation de cris
à nouveau de déprogrammer d'en appeler à
la réserve sanitaire etc etc
christophe prudhomme est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dirais qu'on est
quand même un peu plus en mesure
d'encaisser le choc hier ou que non que
rien n'a changé pour vous maintenant on
va vous et on reçoit les circulaires va
on sait s'organiser ce qu'ils avaient
montré la première vague c'est que l'on
a mais on a su s'organiser sur le
terrain sauf qu'aujourd'hui sans moyens
supplémentaires ça va être très
compliqué nous sommes épuisés nous
sommes moins nombreux parce que
aujourd'hui des gens sont partis les
gens sont malades
donc voilà c'est le résultat d'une
politique qui a été menée depuis vingt
ans et qui ne changent pas
cent mille lits ont été fermés en 25 ans
et on continue à fermer des lits tous
les projets moi ce que je demande
aujourd'hui à monsieur véran c'est
qu'ils stoppent qui stoppe tous les
projets de restructuration qui implique
des fermetures de lits voilà là ça
serait un signe très fort on qu'on
puisse reprendre le dialogue c'est pas
du tout ce qui nous est annoncé au
ministère de la santé et dans les grands
établissements parce que j'ai cités
l'assistance publique mais c'est le cas
à nancy c'est lé cas à orléans c'est le
cas à nantes où toutes les
restructurations
la logique c'est un plus un lunch offert
moins que deux mois j'en ai assez d'être
en réunion où on discute avant tout des
économies qu'on l'a pas fait l'an
dernier des économies qu'on va faire
cette année de celle qu'il faut la faire
l'an prochain moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
discute de la réponse aux besoins de
santé de la population
en tant que médecin et avec mes
collègues infirmières aides-soignantes
c'est ce qui nous intéresse est pâle
équilibre budgétaire nos établissements
a priori même si il faut discuter avant
de redonner effectivement des moyens
mais on ne discute que le ça et ça
commence à suffire d'allier chassaing le
mot de la fin très très très rapidement
car on a beaucoup applaudi pendant tout
c'est pas du premier confinement le
personnel soignant
aujourd'hui alors qu'on s'habitue à
vivre avec le virus et bien toutes ces
revendications elles n'ont pas tout à
fait le même écho auprès de la
population
très rapidement il faut
les soignent à l'hôpital il faut former
davantage parce qu'on vient de dire
qu'il ya pas de personnel mais il ya un
manque de personnel partout il ya des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvus donc il
faut former davantage d'infirmières et
d'aides-soignantes et revaloriser les
professionnels les médecins et
revaloriser aussi les intérimaires pas
les intérimaires mais ceux qui peuvent
garder leur poste et ne pas avoir besoin
de l'intérimaire c'est à dire augmenter
les dotations des gars ben merci merci à
tous les cadres d'avoir participé à ce
débat il ya du pain sur la planche
on est maintenant à une demi heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
nos journalistes sont en place alexandre
poussard salle à des conférences où il
va interviewer ministre sénateur notre
streamer politique jean massiet qui
échangent avec sa communauté autour de
la séance à suivre et puis on est avec
quentin quant à elle mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous détailler un tout petit
peu plus le programme des questions
d'actualité avec plaisir tam
on va revenir largement aujourd'hui sur
la déclaration de claire et dont la
défenseure des droits je vous rappelle
ses propos vendredi dernier madame est
et dont a appelé à mener des
expérimentations dans certains quartiers
comme l'arrêt de contrôle des contrôles
d'identité qui peuvent je cite devenir
insupportable pour certains jeunes cette
phrase provoque depuis lire des
sénateurs de droite et des centristes
également trois questions sont prévues
du groupe l ère du groupe les
indépendants et une question aussi venue
des centristes
et c'est même la toute première question
de cette séance qui est consacrée à ces
propos de claire et donc autres sujets
majeurs aujourd'hui l'éducation
nationale et l'enseignement supérieur on
va parler de la détresse des étudiants
les communistes entendent poser une
question sur la situation sociale des
étudiants
on attend également une question et
l'air pur et bien parler de la première
année de médecine et enfin une question
des socialistes sur les classes et les
postes dans le secondaire
merci merci quentin pour toutes ces
explications et tout de suite on va
rejoindre le point presse
fait brune retailleau le président du
groupe et l'air au sénat qui fait un
point presse est bien pour parler de ce
sujet du vote par anticipation que le
gouvernement veut autoriser l'objectif
de gouvernement je vous le rappelle
c'est de faire baisser l'abstention mais
est bien les sénateurs et notamment la
droite sénatoriale n'apprécie pas du
tout la méthode du gouvernement car pour
introduire cette mesure l'exécutif a
choisi de déposer hier matin un
amendement de dernière minute est ce qui
est débattue demain au sénat tout de
suite on écoute bruno retailleau
catimini c arrive au bout du bout de
l'examen d'un texte sans le contrôle du
conseil d'état comme si le gouvernement
voulait passer sous le radar du contrôle
parlementaire du contrôle du conseil
d'état alors qu'il s'agit quand même de
l'élection du président de la république
c'est l'élection qui est la clé de voûte
de toutes nos institutions
comme si le gouvernement avait honte et
voulait dans la précipitation cacher des
choses qui pourraient être inavouables
et puis il ya le fond il ya deux
critiques qui sont des critiques
extrêmement important d'abord un la
rupture d'égalité parce que il y aura
évidemment un électorat urbain qui sera
aux portes par exemple de la préfecture
et qui pour aller voter
en 10 minutes et puis il y aura les
autres qui auront besoin de faire une
heure deux heures et parfois même plus
pour des départements qui sont plus
éloignés de la préfecture du centre
notamment du département donc il ya
vraiment un avantage donné un type
délectera sans doute peut-être plus
macro n'ya peut-être pense-t-il le
gouvernement que d'autres et puis un
autre aspect c'est que si vous votez 1
mercredi
et s'il se passe avant dimanche
un événement énorme qui peut finalement
vous faire changer d'avis vous ne
pourrez pas changer de votes
or on sait que désormais les votes se
cristallise de plus en plus tardivement
donc ça peut aussi altérer la sincérité
du vote
donc ça n'est ni une méthode et ça sent
la magouille finalement parce que je
n'ai jamais vu notamment pour une
élection de ce type là
des méthodes pareilles au dernier moment
alors même que depuis un an
le sénat a toujours essayé de faire des
propositions pour faire en sorte qu'on
trouve des modalités de vote
en temps de crise sanitaire et que
souvent le gouvernement a rejeté les
propositions que l'on faisait mais c'est
une manoeuvre
c'est vous qui le dites et je leur
prends évidemment je suis surpris parce
que ça nous est tombé dessus et personne
ne s'y attendait je sais y compris
d'ailleurs que au parti majoritaire
ils ont appris quelques heures avant
nous à l'assemblée nationale
cet amendement est est ce qui est
terrible c'est que c'est non seulement
une manoeuvre politicienne mais c'est
une manoeuvre qui est teinté
d'amateurisme pourquoi tout simplement
parce que il ya ce qu'on appelle la
règle de l'entonnoir et que si le sénat
ne vote pas cet amendement et je vois
pas comment il pourrait être voté dans
l'état actuel des choses si le sénat
referme cet article sur lequel
s'accroche au mali dont je me suis dit
attendre si si finalement le sénat le
rejette
ils n'auront pas les moyens à
l'assemblée nationale de le reprendre
pour l'accrocher un article qui ont été
ici voté conforme donc non c'est à la
fois de l'arrière cuisine électorale
bien évidemment mais aussi beaucoup
beaucoup d'amateurisme
non mais ça c'est on vous vend avec
cette app store et bien sûr ça c'est
l'intention ça c'est le le packaging si
j'ose dire ça c'est la méthode de
communication
mais non si vraiment il y avait eu une
intention d'abord il aurait repris un
certain nombre d'idées du sénat voilà
par exemple pour l'élection
présidentielle qu'une même personne
puisse porter deux procurations c'est ce
que nous avions proposé et mais surtout
on n'aurait pas été pris par surprise
encore une fois il s'agit de l'élection
qui est la clé de voûte de nos
institutions
il suppose un travail parlementaire en
amont convoi le pour et le contre
puisque vous savez que pour les machines
à voter il ya un moratoire qui a été
instituée il ya plus de dix ans parce
qu'il y avait des problèmes
alors tout à coup les problèmes se
règlent comme ça non ça n'est pas
sérieux ça n'est pas sérieux
je pense que au moment où on nous parle
beaucoup de cuisine politicienne
on nous parle beaucoup de la
proportionnelle qu'est ce que les
français ont à faire de la
proportionnelle dans ce temps qui est un
temps de crise voilà
dix ans on va étaler des votes avant -
le monde le jour j et ainsi éviter
l'affluence on le sait important dans l
après vente et imaginons qu'on est
encore en crise sanitaire d'encadrement
m'écouter ça fait un an que le sénat
fait des propositions tous les deux mois
de vote électronique
on a même évoqué un moment donné le vote
par correspondance on est allé aussi sur
le vote par une procuration c'est à dire
qu'une même personne pourrait avoir deux
procurations
on a fait toutes ces propositions elles
ont toujours été rejetées
et là tout à coup il ya un amendement
qui arrivent par surprise en catimini
il n'a pas fait l'objet d'une étude
sérieuse d'un examen sérieuse du conseil
d'état pour en vérifier les aspects
juridiques et autres la sécurité aussi
dès lors qu'il s'agit de vote
électronique est un problème de sécurité
et souvent le gouvernement nous l'a dit
nous l'a répété il ya quelques mois
non je franchement je sale a encore une
fois on nous dit qu'il s'agit de tenir
compte de la crise sanitaire
je pense qu'il s'agit surtout de tenir
compte des intérêts électoraux du
président de république
voyez je pense que il ya un électorat
urbain qui serait plus avantagés par
rapport à un autre électorat
voilà si on sait jamais peut-être que
cet électorat
il a envie d'aller en villégiature si
jamais il faisait beau ce dimanche là il
préférait peut-être voté quelques jours
avant non peut-être une hypothèse sans
doute fausse mais je le lave ans en tout
cas en tout cas cette rupture d'égalité
entre ce qui serait proche d'une machine
à voter et c'est ce qui en serait très
éloignées pose un vrai problème et c'est
peut-être même un problème
constitutionnel
je suis pas du tout sûr que le conseil
constitutionnel puisse approuver ce
genre de pratiques d'où peut-être
d'où peut-être la ruse du gouvernement
pour éviter pour éviter un examen en
amont de ce dispositif de cet amendement
par le conseil d'état
en l'état
demain à la séance puisque vous lavant
va le maintenir le 2 mai en six ans vous
ne voterez passe à table non mais vous
savez je vois très très peu de groupes
qui serait d'accord pour le voter parce
que c'est des amendements ça n'est pas
notre tradition républicaine française
voilà et donc si il ya quelques semaines
on avait eu cartes sur table pour
étudier vraiment les conséquences toutes
les conséquences les conséquences parce
qu'avec le numérique il peut y avoir des
intrusions peut y avoir des hackers il
peut y avoir énormément
ces gens se dire d'effets collatéraux si
on avait pu l'étudier
peut-être qu'on aurait dit oui si on
avait été convaincu mémé faire les
choses en l'état
en catimini dans la précipitation
saccage de mauvaises intentions
en tout cas si l'intention avait été
bonne et bien cet amendement aurait
suivi le parcours classique avec le
conseil d'état
un rapport est surtout une étude
approfondie du parlement mais là on ne
nous a pas laissé le temps de voir les
conséquences toutes les conséquences de
ce dispositif
et encore une fois il s'agit de
démocratie et je crois que la démocratie
française quand on voit le taux de
participation et d'abstention et
méritent mieux justement que ces petits
coups politiques deux derniers moments
qui ont tendance à éveiller le soupçon
vous prédécesseur
si on peut voter un qui garde à vue
je ne serai pas déclaration surtout
triste je ne serai pas déclaration sur
le sujet mais précis mais de toute façon
il me semble j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau valérie
létard bonjour un jour vous êtes
sénatrice union centriste du nord et
vice présidente du sénat également sur
ce plateau eric kerrouche joue sénat ce
sénateur socialiste des landes et
précise qui vous est notamment à
l'origine d'une proposition de loi
déposée au mois de novembre dernier pour
instaurer le vote par correspondance
pour l'élection présidentielle ça fait
partie un petit peu des sujets qu'on va
évoquer maintenant valérie létard est ce
que vous êtes aussi remonté que bruno
retailleau que vos collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale qui parle de
magouilles hervé marseille qui parle
d'un objet politiquement non identifiés
et ce matin la commission des lois qui
dit on ne joue pas de cette façon avec
l'élection présidentielle mais vous avez
tout dit en résumant ses formules qui en
fait disent quoi un qu'on peut discuter
de tous quelle que soit la question mais
pas sous cette forme là bas comme ça pas
selon une méthode qui fait filles en
fait de toutes les contributions de tous
les apports de toutes les réflexions il
ya une méthode il y à un moment pour
tout et quand on aborde un sujet qui
touche en plus aux élections
présidentielles on ne parle pas d'une
expérimentation sur une élection
municipale pour voir l'effectivité du en
fait d'un processus de vote qui vise à
ramener plus d'électeurs jusqu'aux urnes
d'encourager le vote mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui et j'en resterai là pour
l'instant on est dans quelque chose qui
voit là un kit de l'incompréhension
totale et du mépris par rapport à toutes
les institutions existantes par rapport
au parlement par rapport au travail fait
par la commission des lois
l'association des maires de france ce
sont les merles y mettent en oeuvre ces
questions le conseil d'état qui n'est
pas saisie puisque de toute façon passe
par voie d'amendement
tout cela fait vraiment désordre tout
cela n'est pas acceptable
toute idée doit être examiné ça c'est
vraiment prendre tous les risques du
monde sur une élection majeure
eric kerrouche sur la forme aussi pour
vous c'est regrettable
moment de dernière minute déposées sur
un texte a priori technique sapers
laissé à personne le temps de réellement
bien travaillé le sujet en tout cas la
proposition du gouvernement
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
proposition sur la forme comme sur le
fond est incongru et c'est vraiment
j'essaie vraiment gênant parce que selon
moi c'est la meilleure façon de tuer une
bonne idée c'est à dire que bien entendu
et on le dit en ce qui nous concerne
depuis des mois il faut adapter notre
droit électoral
votre par correspondance éventuellement
votre vote anticipé encore fait vous
n'êtes pas contre un pour pouvoir
améliorer la participation c'était même
l'objet de vos propositions
les je pense que notre droit électoral
doit être améliorée non seulement en
raison de la période que l'on traverse
mais de façon plus générale
mais là vu la façon dont paris la
proposition et vu ce qu'elle contient
c'est vraiment ce qu'il fallait faire
pour dévitalisées complètement tout le
débat sur le sujet allez tout de suite
on va rejoindre alexandre poussard salle
des conférences pour une réaction celle
du président de votre groupe
éric kerrouche le socialiste patrick
kanner oui l'état mais d'abord je
voudrais dire que selon les informations
de notre site internet publicsenat.fr et
bien cet amendement pour un vote par
anticipation à l'élection présidentielle
serait en train d'être entré enterré
d'être abandonnés par le gouvernement
selon nos informations patrick kanner
d'avoir une réaction
est ce que vous êtes satisfait par un
éventuel abandon de cette mesure je suis
d'abord mais mes collègues les tarés qui
rouge qui sont en plateau
aujourd'hui ça montre qu'on est dans le
n'importe quoi excusez moi quand même
avoir fait
autant de bruit autour de ce tas
mandement sur le thème de la
modernisation de la démocratie pour
peut-être aujourd'hui le retirer parce
que finalement il est très mal ficelé
tant sur le contenu que pour certains
sur le fond sur le fond nous nous sommes
favorables nous pensons que le vote par
anticipation une bonne chose mais pas
dans les conditions aujourd'hui gérée
par le gouvernement il ya un problème
sur la forme sur le fond en quoi c'est
une bonne chose ce votre article et nous
nous croyons aux groupes socialistes
écologistes et républicains que
l'abstention et qui n'est pas univoque
comme le dit souvent mon collègue éric
et rouge
l'abstention est un mal pour la
démocratie est un poison pour la
démocratie est un poison qui est lent et
qui peut aboutir à des confusions
amenant vers les populismes et l'extrême
droite donne très concrètement et donc
tout ce qui peut permettre et favoriser
la participation des habitants
le vote classique mais aussi le vote par
correspondance le vote par anticipation
comme cela s'est fait aux états unis je
crois que c'est une modernisation du
processus électoral devant lequel il ne
faut pas avoir peur et pourtant si on
vote quelques jours avant le scrutin et
qu'il ya des événements de campagne est
ce que ça ne peut pas faussé le vote
mais tout dépend savez je tout d'abord
il n'ya pas toujours des événements qui
fausse le vote pour vraiment
deuxièmement il suffit de l'organiser de
telle manière que justement il n'est pas
de difficulté et c'est sur un choix
personne ne vous oblige à voter par
anticipation
mais le faire c'est un plus je crois
pour le bon fonctionnement de
l'institution est ce qu on pourrait par
exemple imaginer de pouvoir voter
cinq jours avant et si jamais et bien il
ya un événement pouvoir voter nous ne
sommes pas favorables à 5 jours avant on
était sur deux à trois jours précédant
le vote avec une fluidification s'avère
regardez ce qui s'est passé au portugal
il n'y a pas très longtemps
250000 portugais ont voté par tancé par
anticipation avant le vote présidentiel
du dimanche à l'échelle de la france
c'est un million et demi de français qui
se serait déplacé si on fait une
comparaison de population population et
bien moi je ne crache pas entre
guillemets bien au contraire sur cette
mobilisation citoyenne qui peut être
favorisé par la multiplication des
dispositifs favorisant le vote
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à mes questions donc vous le
voyez terme en ce vote par par
anticipation sur le fond eh bien ça
séduit le président des sénateurs
socialistes
merci beaucoup alexandre on reste bien
aux conditions
n'allons nous parlerait d'un
rétropédalage du gouvernement sur cet
amendement je vous parle je vous indique
quand même hein ce que prévoyait
l'amendement du gouvernement s'est
instauré donc un vote par anticipation
pour l'élection présidentielle les
électeurs peuvent demander à voter dans
une autre commune de leur choix parmi
une liste de communes arrêté par le
ministre de l'intérieur
le vote par anticipation a lieu à une
date fixée par décret durant la semaine
qui précède le scrutin et enfin le vote
par anticipation est effectuée sur une
machine à voter et les suffrages sont
dépouillés en même temps que les autres
bureaux de la commune sur le fond qu'est
ce qui vous fait tiquer dans tout ce
dispositif vous valérie létard et bien
franchement ça mérite déjà un gros
travail en commissions et on peut pas
donner effectivement nu une analyse
toute fine et tout fait comme ça mais
les questions elles ont déjà été enfin
les inquiétudes causées par les uns les
autres les risques de rupture d'égalité
la temporalité c'est vrai qu'il peut se
passer des événements entre un vote
anticipé et le vote
en fait le jour donné caisse comme en
anglais sur son vote éventuel la rupture
d'égalité aussi entre quoi entre une
personne qui habite dans la ruralité une
personne qui est dans l'urbain si on a
un endroit où on peut faire allez vous
voter sur une machine à voter une incite
par département comment les gens peuvent
se déplacer
il faut s'inscrire préalablement sur une
plateforme numérique comment le fait-on
quand on n'a pas accès au numérique des
questions et son poste d'état peut-être
peuvent-elles être résolus peut-être
qu'il y a des solutions monsieur
kerrouche en propose certaines est ce
que c'est le bon moyen et j'attire votre
attention aujourd'hui on n'a aucun recul
sur cela et le peu de recul qu'on a et
pour la présidence et nice apparaît
quand même mais le ministère de la
hier affirmant le risque enfin l'outil
comme obsolètes les risques juridiques
organisationnels le ministère de
l'intérieur
on peut s'interroger et donc on le voit
bien il ya beaucoup de points
d'interrogations champ d'expérimentation
sur les présidentielles
ça me paraît quand même extrêmement
risqué pour autant moi comme monsieur
caire où je suis convaincu qu'il faut
qu'on chope mines
il faut faire évoluer les choses
maintenant sous quelle forme
à quel moment ça fait un an que le coz
idée là un nom qu'on travaille dans les
différentes chambres sur ces questions
pourquoi maintenant sous cette forme
la verticalité pas de consultation pas
des changes de partage sur les bonnes
idées rien rien pas de discussions c'est
dommage pourquoi maintenant eric pierre
rochefort pose la question que pose
valérie létard on entend par exemple
bruno retailleau dubaï a des intentions
politicienne
est-ce qu'il veut favoriser emmanuel
macron son électorat électorat urbain
contre l'électorat rural et c est ce que
pour vous il ya des intentions
politicienne derrière cette proposition
qui dit vouloir avant tout lutter contre
l'abstention je le répète si vous voulez
le scénario est tellement mal ficelé
rare que forcément ça amène à se poser
des questions sur la tension est
justement c'est typiquement ce qu'il ne
faut pas quand on réfléchit au droit
électoral
il faut y poser il faut il penser de
façon posée réfléchie en travaillant
collectivement et sûrement pas sur un
coup du sort qui nous arrive
probablement deux chez jupiter et ont
donc sereinement pour vous aujourd'hui
alors qu'on est à treize mois de
l'élection présidentielle serait il est
encore temps d'avoir une réflexion
sereine
si vous voulez au bout d'un moment c'est
jamais le membre moi je constate qu'une
chose autour de nous la plupart des
démocraties occidentales
d'abord continue à tenir leur élection
parce que ça fait partie de la vie comme
j'allais dire les autres secteurs de
notre vie du quotidien
l'élection c'est important pas plus que
le reste mais au moins autant par tous à
évoluer partout ça a évolué les
élections se tiennent
pourquoi on serait les seuls à ne pas
être capable d'adapter notre droit
électoral
c'est la question mais pas dans ces
conditions dit dans ces circonstances
allez on va tout de suite et aller voir
jeanjean massiet notre streamer
politique qui est en train lui même
présenter sa propre émission sur twitch
sur la plateforme avec toute sa
communauté d'internautes on parle ici
pas malin du vote par anticipation genre
qu'est ce qui préoccupe les internautes
aujourd'hui un nom mais écoute à
mouiller le vote par anticipation c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet on en parle
depuis 24 heures alors alors c'est quoi
cette histoire qu'est ce que veut le
gouvernement
beaucoup de questions sont posées on
demande des clarifications ici on
aimerait bien que les sénateurs et des
sénatrices pose des questions au
gouvernement sur ce sujet qu'est ce que
veut faire le gouvernement
pourquoi et puis quand on commence à en
parler de ce vote par anticipation et
bah je ne le cache pas il ya un vrai
débat aille à ceux qui sont plutôt pour
disons que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
ça peut permettre aux gens qui bossent
le dimanche ça ceux qui habitent à
l'étranger ou alors dans une ville à
côté
bref tout un tas de raisons ça peut être
assez pratique ce vote par anticipation
mais figure toi que ce qui fait vraiment
débat chez les internautes c'est plutôt
le caractère électronique du vote
anticipé si c'est une machine à voter il
y en a plein qui sont pas chauds en
disant qu' il ya quand même des risques
de fraude on n'a jamais vraiment conçu
confiance dans cette technologie et
d'autres qui disent qu après tout
pourquoi pas si c'est sécurisé que ce
soit électronique ou en papier
peu importe le vente anticipée n'est pas
forcément une mauvaise idée dont
vraiment des débats qui sont qui sont
qui sont soulevées par cette question
l'autre sujet que les internautes
attendent dans la séance de questions
d'actualité tout à l'heure c'est
frédéric vidal la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui a annoncé qu'une enquête
allait être lancée sur l'islamo
gauchisme à l'université alors beaucoup
d'étudiants se posent la question en
disant mais pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
s'intéresse à ça maintenant on est en
plein en pleine crise étudiantes des
vrais des défis des défunts des
situations de vie et de précarité qui
sont très difficiles à vivre et la
ministre qui est censé s'occuper de nous
elle va lutter contre un islam au
gauchisme chez des chercheurs on n'a pas
très bien compris de quoi là on demande
des clarifications de la part de
fabrique vidal voilà un petit peu les
deux sujets si tu veux tam qui sont
attendues de la part des internautes
pour la séance et ben écoute ça tombe
bien parce que justement vallée salle
des conférences rejoindre alexandre
alexandre qui est avec eux pierre rose
olias sénateurs commises des
hauts-de-seine il va poser une question
lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité autour de la situation des
étudiants mais il va aussi réagir à
cette annonce
très polémique hier de frédéric vidal en
effectivement pierre ouzoulias ce je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur de
profession comment vous avez
l'annnonce de cette enquête sur le monde
de la recherche et de l'université sur
l' influence d'un pseudo courant de
pensée d'islam au gauchisme
je suis effondré effondré c'est triste
pour la science française qu'une
ministre reprennent comme ça et valide
les thèses de l'extrême droite parce que
islamo gauchistes c'est un concept pensé
par l'extrême droite comme le grand
remplacement
donc après monsieur darmanin qui dit que
madame le pen et mollassonne la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
culture fait la publicité de l'extrême
droite je crois que malheureusement ce
gouvernement est un train de préparer
les résistible ascension dans la prise
du pouvoir de l'extrême droite
il faudrait que les républicains et les
anti fascistes se réunissent se
réunissent c'est-à-dire pour répondre
pour pour faire front à aujourd'hui une
banalisation des propos d'extrême droite
des concepts fasciste qui n'ont pas
raison qu'ils ne sont pas fondées sur
une analyse raisonnable ou moi je je
reprends le communiqué de la conférence
des présidents d'université qui est une
institution ancienne noble qu'à 50 ans
et qui demande à la ministre d'arrêter
les arguties de casser du commerce
vous vous rendez compte où on en est je
sais catastrophique pour l'image de
notre pays
quand vous dites il faut que les
républicains se réunissent est ce que ça
veut dire que cette enquête du
gouvernement est anti républicaine selon
vous hélas anticonstitutionnelle et la
anticonstitutionnelle parce que mais la
ministre le sait je comprends pas
comment elles puissent feindre de
l'ignorer
un professeur d'université à ses
libertés académiques qui sont défendues
par la constitution
donc on peut pas demander un autre
organisme comme le cnrs de venir
enquêter sur ces travaux universitaires
et je sincèrement je suis effondré pour
le propos et par la méconnaissance
absolue de ce que sont les institutions
universitaires françaises il faudrait
rappeler les ministres que les libertés
académiques elles ont été fondés en
france 112 115 par la sorbonne
c'est notre héritage commun il faudrait
qu'elle le défendent est-ce que c'est
l'urgence en ce moment de lancer ce
genre d' enquête alors qu'il ya un vrai
malaise étudiants non mais je crois que
la ministre est incapable de répondre au
malaise étudiants donc elle ouvre un
contre-feu avec les allumettes du front
national c'est catastrophique
elle doit rester en poste la ministre a
endossé son c'est le problème c'est
celui de sa conscience avec elle même
moi je je je l'inciterai à à partir si
je crois qu'elle a plus rien à faire à
la tête du ministère de la connaissance
merci beaucoup pierre aux liasses pour
votre réaction merci alexandre cela
pendant que votre interview on voyait
arriver bien la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
frédéric vidal votre réaction
on trade évident qu'ils demandent donc
une étude scientifique au cnrs pour je
la cite définir ce qui relève de la
recherche et du militantisme c'est
légitime s'est lassé de la chasse aux
sorcières c'est la chasse aux chercheurs
qu'est ce que c'est alors les temps
chercheur cnrs de profession je me sens
concerné je prends les choses de manière
un peu un peu un peu direct dans ses
sept ministres était inexistante elle
devient pathétique c'est pas plus que ça
elle est censée s'occuper de la détresse
des étudiants et des étudiantes en ce
moment qui est extrêmement forte on a de
multiples de multiples témoignages et
ont choisi d'aller dans la polémique
peut-être que justement parce qu'on va
dans la polémique parce qu'on ne sait
pas traiter le problème de fond qui est
le plus important
que fait-on de notre jeunesse et dans
cette jeunesse que fait-on de notre
jeunesse étudiante et il est évident que
pour moi elle a fini de se discréditer
valérie létard oui c'est une diversion
c'est vrai qu'on se dit qu'en ce moment
les étudiants vivent une situation très
difficile
les questions se multiplient d'ailleurs
toutes les semaines aux séances de
questions d'actualité sur la condition
étudiante on a encore une
aujourd'hui c'est la priorité du moment
cette enquête que lance la mini ce mail
non mais c'est une fois de plus c'est
l'incompréhension sur la méthode le
pourquoi maintenant au moment où on le
sait on rentre dans les difficultés qui
sont liées à une longue période de coded
où les étudiants et le monde étudiant au
sens large du terme a été quand même
victime et de plein fouet
on commence
voir les conséquences sociales
psychologiques on voit les difficultés
que ça va donner même dans la poursuite
d'études pour atteindre un niveau des
compétences pour entrer dans la vie
professionnelle
les sujets sont énormes venir s'attaquer
à ce sujet faudra peut-être s'y attaquer
un jour et encore mois très honnêtement
je ne suis contrairement à monsieur
kerrouche pas une spécialiste de ces
questions mais s'il ya bien une chose en
tant que citoyenne et lui que je connais
et que je vois tous les jours dans mon
territoire et qu'on voit dans ce pays
c'est eu l'extrême urgence d'être au
rendez-vous de mesurer d'une réflexion
en profondeur sur un plan marshall pour
notre jeunesse et pour notre jeunesse
étudiante st
eh ben pour le coup le plan de relance
par exemple on ferait bien de le teinter
de cette réflexion et ça ça pourrait
occuper notre ministre utilement alors
on est maintenant à moins de cinq
minutes du début des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement je voudrais
qu'on revienne un petit peu sur le sujet
que l'on évoqué avant de parler de la
situation des étudiants inquiets peut
être aussi liée à la pandémie la
pandémie qui a pu occasionner est bien
d'aider report notamment d'élections
on parlait tout à l'heure du fait gens
nous parler du fait que le recours à des
machines à voter fait débat auprès même
des internautes certains disent aussi
des machines à voter je suis je suis pas
du tout sûr on va rappeler quand même
que depuis 2008 six machines elles font
l'objet d'un moratoire que les communes
qui disposent déjà de machines à voter
non pas le droit d'en changer
donc elles sont souvent obsolètes et
celles qui n'en n'ont pas pour l'instant
n'ont pas le droit d'en acquérir riquet
rouge déjà une première difficulté
matérielle importante à la proposition
du gouvernement
oui sachant que le moratoire n'a pas été
levé donc c'est vrai c'est un vrai
problème
et puis plus fondamentalement je suis
profondément technophiles et c'est
justement parce que je suis technophile
que je suis contre les machines à voter
dès qu'il y à une intermédiation par une
machine même fermé dès qu'on a accès à
cette machine qu'elles soient reliés à
un réseau ou pas on peut contourner les
résultats de notre road
ça a été montré de multiples fois il n'y
a aucune machine à voter qu'ils soient à
l'épreuve de la fraude et de temps en
temps
eh bien le système que l'on connaît le
système historique de 20
et sans doute le meilleur donc source de
fraude valérie létard on entend même du
côté de la république en marche une voix
comme celle de xavier iacovelli qui dit
qu'il est contre il dit ça fait 13 ans
que je suis élu local
je me suis toujours opposé au vote
électronique et notamment aux machines à
voter dans les communes il a indiqué
notamment que pour lui ça avait été
source a peut-être pas de fraude mis là
au moins indiqué qu'il y avait eu
beaucoup de bugs beaucoup de difficultés
avec le caractère très obsolètes
aujourd'hui de ces machines dans les
communes effectivement d'abord ça existe
moi je sais que dans dans mon
arrondissement il ya une commune qui en
fait utilise une machine à voter depuis
très longtemps
pour autant une machine à voter
nécessite de se déplacer c'est hier
qu'on passe pas dans le bus et dans
l'isoloir enfin en ce 11 ans précise son
vote sur une machine qui nécessite de se
déplacer donc ça règle pas forcément les
problèmes c'est différent du vote par
internet que par exemple les français de
l'étranger peuvent pratiquer pour
l'élection ou la nouveauté par
ordinateurs interposés
quand on dit le vote électronique en
tout cas c'est dans son ex ami jean
large et plusieurs choses le ministère
de l'intérieur lui même s'est exprimé il
ya quelques semaines voire quelques mois
à peine pour dire tout le mal qu'ils
pensaient jardin la nasa jeudi dans les
récipients à thouars pour regarder
justement à expliciter ses risques et
ses dangers organisationnel encore une
fois le juridique il y en a énormément
et s'engager dans cette voie aujourd'hui
alors que le même le ministère de
l'intérieur n'y crois pas c'est quand
même compliqué ça paraît effectivement
compliqué écouter on va voir en tout cas
si cet amendement va rester puisque et
bien le texte va être examiné demain
dans l'hémicycle du sénat merci merci
beaucoup
ça va aller
d'avoir participé à ces face-à-face
merci beaucoup éric kerrouche en est
maintenant le début de cette séance de
questions d'actualité et imminent va
tout de suite et bien rejoindre quentin
qu'elle met dans l'hémicycle du sénat
alors que l'on voit gérard larcher qui
quitte le cabinet de départ un point sur
et bien ce qu'on attend de ces questions
d'actualité quentin et bien tam sur les
seize questions au programme aujourd'hui
pas moins de trois sont consacrés aux
propos de la défenseure des droits
madame et donc qui a parlé de cette
expérimentation dans certains quartiers
comme l'arrêt des contrôles d'identité
ces propos ont fait réagir et font
réagir beaucoup la droite ici à la
chambre haute
autre sujet majeur aujourd'hui il y est
consacré à l'éducation nationale et ou à
l'enseignement supérieur on va parler de
la détresse des étudiants on va
également parlé la situation des élèves
et des étudiants en première année de
médecine et enfin la suppression des
classes et des postes et des passes dans
le secondaire avec une question des
socialistes on attend également une
question sur la tacc informatique a
touché un hôpital à dax également une
question sur le parlement européen qui
mesure une qui ne se réunit plus à
strasbourg c'est parti pour cette séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement n'ont pas reçu
d'observation y'en a t'il en séance
j'envoie point le procès verbal est donc
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre et dames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
l'offre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et notre site internet
nous veillerons au respect du temps
respect des uns et des autres mais au
respect
des gestes prophylactique dont nous
avons maintenant bien l'habitude ce qui
me permet de saluer nos collègues qui
accepte et en tribunes du public pour
que nous respections bien les jauges qui
ont été fixés j'aurais m'a tant donné la
parole à notre collègue dany wattebled
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires jamais apparu
méprisant monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues alors que la république se bat
pour se maintenir son autorité sur
l'ensemble du territoire national alors
que nos forces de l'ordre font face à
une dangereuse montée en puissance de la
délinquance et de la violence et alors
que nos concitoyens subissent
quotidiennement les effets de la
sécurité la défenseure des droits de
l'homme à idées pour le moins saugrenue
expérimenter des zones sans contrôle
d'identité
cette proposition est ahurissante
pourquoi ne pas expérimenter des zones
sans policiers des zones sans pompiers
est finalement des zones sans droits
selon soudain pays et nos concitoyens ce
n'est pas d'un trop grand respect de la
loi mais deux sont insuffisantes
application notre pays et notre et nos
concitoyens souffrent du désordre du
manque du respect de certains pour la
loi l'autorité
madame la défenseure des droits de
l'homme a le droit de fin de droits
et bien sûr le droit des gens à vivre en
sécurité dans leur immense majorité les
foncé sont bien conscients de l'essai de
lutter contre l'insécurité qui les
menacent ils savent que les forces de
l'ordre interviennent avec beaucoup de
difficultés dans certains quartiers et
ils ne montrent pas moins de police bien
au contraire la discrimination n'a pas
sa place dans le pays dans notre
république
mais la proposition de madame la
défenseure des droits de neka un
renoncement une république à deux
vitesses où les loi s'appliquerait selon
les quartiers elle contient une
institution insupportable elle laisse
entendre qu'un contrôle d'identité
seraient forcément contrôles au faciès
et qu'il faudrait arrêter ces contrôles
policiers gendarmes rempli leur mission
avec exemplarité et ceux qui manquent à
leurs devoirs sont sévèrement punis
nous voulons assurer ici aux forces de
l'ordre tout notre soutien
monsieur le ministre pouvait confirmer
que cette expérimentation n'aura pas
lieu car il est vital d'assurer
l'autorité de l'état dans tous les
territoires de république
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre et
la parole monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur comme vous le savez toutes et
tous la défenseure des droits autorités
pour laquelle nous avons tous beaucoup
de respect est une autorité
administrative indépendante qui
formulent un certain nombre de
préconisations
il se trouve que le gouvernement de la
république est également indépendant de
la défenseure des droits et que
avec tout le respect je le reste répète
dû à cette institution
je dis solennellement devant le sénat et
devant le pays qu'il n'y a pas et qu'il
n'y aura pas de zone sans contrôle
d'identité en application des lois de la
république je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame la présidente catherine de roche
pour le groupe breivik avait la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur
nous le savions bien la fin du numerus
clausus n'était pas la fin de la
sélection en effet les murs des facultés
ne sont pas extensibles pas plus que les
les terrains de stage ou les nombres des
enseignants chargés de l'est de les
former néanmoins la loi de 2019
promettait de mettre fin au gâchis des
abandons après redoublement
elle promettait de diversifier le
parcours des recrutements et elle
promettait aussi d'avoir un traitement
équitable entre les étudiants passant
par le parcours passe la licence l'ass
ou les redoublante de la paces le nombre
de postes devaient définies par les
universités en lien avec les intéresse
et ce en effet pour tenir compte des du
territoire mais également des capacités
des universités auront cette année si
particulière les espoirs levée par le
passage du numerus clausus au numerus à
perthus laisse place à du désarroi de l'
angoisse est vraiment une inquiétude
chez les étudiants en médecine
donc il semble qu'en effet qu'un flou
percée sur le nombre de places rhénan
ouverte et et est-ce que et que dans
certaines facultés le nombre de places
déjà réservé aux redoublants de la paces
laisse la portion congrue ou à la
première promotion de de la réforme
qu'elle ne pourra pas redoubler donc ma
question est simple dames 2010 qu'en est
il exactement
pour vous répondre la parole les cas la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche l'innovation malavida vous
avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice alors vous
vous l'avez rappelé un la loi ma santé
nous a permis de supprimer cette année
pour la première fois mais aussi c'est
vrai dans des conditions universitaire
très particulière lapasset c est le
numerus clausus l'objectif
vous l'avez rappelé aussi c'est de faire
en sorte que nous puissions diversifier
les voies d'accès et surtout que nous
puissions commencer à lutter
efficacement contre la désertification
médicale puisque pouvoir commencer ses
études sur ce son lieu de résidence
pouvoir faire des stages sur son lieu de
résidence à voir des tuteurs sur son
lieu de résidence
eh bien ça évite d'éloigner pendant 15
ans les étudiants de ces fameux lieu de
résidence dans lesquelles parfois on a
du mal à les faire revenir ses 450 cette
licence avec des 1009 santé qui ont été
ouvertes partout sur le territoire
et là encore la plus grande place a été
donnée aux discussions entre les
universités les ars les acteurs locaux
pour définir le nombre de places pour
accéder en deuxième année des études de
santé
ce nombre de places étant évidemment
augmenté par rapport à l'année dernière
c'est une obligation
comment est-ce que les choses se mettent
en place d'abord pour les redoublants de
la paces ancienne version
il nous est apparu important de
maintenir un nombre de places équivalent
en moyenne à la réussite des trois
dernières années en des redoublants en
paces et donc c'est ainsi que les places
ont été calculés pour les premières
années de la rai qui rentre dans la
réforme donc au travers de ces nouvelles
formules
c'est au minimum la réussite moyenne des
trois dernières années c'est donc là que
l'on va voir l'augmentation des places
mais vous le savez madame la sénatrice
en réalité la paces faisait que le
maximum de reçus étaient des redoublants
de la paces et non pas des primo
entrants et puis bien sûr pour tous ceux
qui auront réussi leur première année
dans cette nouvelle formule il y aura
passage en deuxième année et deuxième
chance pour pouvoir accéder aux études
de santé sur merci madame la présidente
de catherine ii roche merci madame la
ministre entend tous ces chiffres en
effet c'était l'objectif de la loi et
c'était les engagements de la loi
alors je veux bien les entendre je vous
fais confiance sur ces chiffres bien
évidemment mais il ya vraiment un
problème de compréhension part parce que
nous sommes en effet sollicité à la fois
par des étudiants mais aussi par des
familles d'étudiants mais aussi il ya eu
des doyens qui se sont exprimés sur le
sujet est vraiment la médecine c'est un
métier de vocation les étudiants dans
cette période difficile montre combien
ils sont impliqués d'ailleurs dans la
crise est vraiment il faut leur laisser
de l'espoir
il ne faudrait pas que la réforme
numerus clausus soit moins bonne que
celle qu'elle était initialement prévu
merci
la parole est à notre collègue michel
logis pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre la ville de
trappes est à la une des médias pour
avoir été maire de la ville voisine et
président de la communauté
d'agglomération dont trappe fait partie
je suis meurtri par la stigmatisation
médiatique dont cette ville fait l'objet
grâce au plan borloo l'anru et centaines
de millions d'euros ont été investis des
immeubles démoli puis reconstruit des
équipements publics flambant neuf le
changement visuel est évident mais hélas
les problématiques sont toujours là et
s'intensifie dans certains quartiers une
véritable pandémie avec un variant
islamiste particulièrement nocifs
toutefois il ne faut pas résumer trappe
à cela car le véritable travail est fait
sur le terrain entre les représentants
de l'état et les élus locaux
nous voulions pas voir ses efforts
anéantis par les déclarations
tonitruantes d'un professeur d'homère
qui tente de défendre sa vie de certes
mais qui se permet de distribuer des
documents dans l'enceinte d'un lycée des
personnes menacées de mort qui sont
aujourd'hui sur surveillance policière
et des partis populistes qui surf sur la
vague en cette période préélectorale
cette polémique éclate alors que l'on
n'en compte plus les flambées de
violence ont peu partout sur le
territoire
à besançon avec une agression raciste
ultra violent
à montbéliard avec des actes de
sauvagerie de guérilla urbaine pour
lesquels le mak oleg annick jacques mais
voulait aussi vous interpeller à paris
avec le lynchage abominable du jeune
gorille à poissy avec un guet-apens
couplé d'un appel au meurtre
pour ne citer que les plus récents face
à ces situations la police semblent
dépassées et c'est dans ce contexte
comme l'a dit mon collègue que la
nouvelle défenseur des droits propose
d'expérimenter des zones se contrôler
l'identité des déclarations faut
l'avouer qui ont semé le doute sur
l'engagement du gouvernement à lutter
contre la criminalité et la sécurité
pouvez vous nous confirmer monsieur le
premier ministre que le gouvernement va
réagir avec les moyens nécessaires au
climat d'instabilité qui sévit dans
certains quartiers partout en france
pour vous répondre la parole et co
milices de l'intérieur monsieur d'armada
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs en m'excusant de quelques
instants de retard et notamment à la
question de saint-albert et je sais que
ce premier ministre je l'en remercie a
répondu j'aurais d'abord est évoqué
trois sujets dans votre question
monsieur sénateurs d'abord la question
de trappes il n'est pas question pour le
gouvernement de montrer un territoire
plutôt qu'un autre et en moyenne un élu
est un territoire difficile
je sais combien les élus combien les
acteurs associatifs room et les
enseignants combien tous ceux qui
concourent à la beauté d'une ville même
lorsqu'il ya des difficultés on voit
parfois leurs efforts ruinés par
effectivement un événement médiatique
deuxièmement évidemment que ce soit le
professeur qui a le droit en république
de dire ce qu'il souhaite
et de dénoncer les menaces et
intimidations et aussi l'état d'une
société qu'ils constatent comme ma mère
doivent être protégés par la revue
lorsqu'ils sont menacés dans les deux
cas ils le sont par les services de
police et nous appartient pas de
trancher un différend politique
et troisièmement il ya bien sûr attrape
comme ailleurs des endroits où
effectivement l'islamisation gagne ou le
travail des islamistes efforts et en
face s'offrent républicaine être encore
plus sévère c'est ce que fait jean
michel blanquer pour l'éducation
nationale c'est ce que fait emmanuel
bon sur la question de l'anru et nous
aurons l'occasion de le voir j'espère
dans quelques jours ensemble sur la
question du séparatisme et puis vous
évoquez enfin la question de la des
policiers qui semble le dépasse et oui
il ya des actes de violence dans notre
pays mais c'est toujours la police qui
gagne dans la sphère youri les personnes
qui sont responsables ces situations ont
été arrêtés et sont sous la main
d'autorité judiciaire dans la sphère de
besançon c'est la même chose dans la
ferme de valence c'est la même histoire
et dans la sphère de poissy les
policiers des lots mains de la visite
des lendemains de cette agression sont
retournés sur le terrain et ont pu
interpeller deux personnes alors oui le
territoire de la république sont parfois
attaquer et bien évidemment que nous
devons renforcer les moyens matériels et
humains de la police non surtout redire
que l'autorité est au coeur du pacte
républicain et qu'à chaque fois cette
autorité doit l'emporter à trappes comme
ailleurs merci la parole et à notre
collègue keyrouz oulias pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
j'ai pris la liberté de m'adresser à
vous monsieur le premier ministre parce
que vous répondez souvent aux questions
qui concernent l'université dans cet
hémicycle
monsieur le premier ministre les
étudiants ont faim dans cet hémicycle
nous sommes nombreux à participer à des
collectes alimentaires pour leur
apporter dans l'extrême urgence des
moyens de subsistance dont beaucoup sont
cruellement privé avant la pandémie près
de la moitié des étudiants travailler
pour pouvoir étudier aujourd'hui la très
grande majorité d'entre eux est privé de
ses emplois votre gouvernement vient
d'annoncer la prolongation de la prime
versée aux salariés intermittents qui
n'ont pu travailler correctement en 2020
cent soixante mille jeunes de moins de
30 ans vont bénéficier de cette mesure
le président de la république a déclaré
qu'un étudiant doit avoir les mêmes
droits qu'à salariés monsieur le
ministre
alors pourquoi les étudiants ont-ils été
exclues de ce dispositif
votre gouvernement vient d'annoncer le
versement d'une prime de 1000 euros pour
aider les jeunes à payer leur loyer
les jeunes apprentis en alternance
pourront
bénéficier de cette prime alors monsieur
le premier ministre pour quoi
les étudiants ont ils étaient exclus de
ce dispositif
monsieur le premier ministre pour quoi
la politique du quoi qu'il en coûte
s'est arrêtée systématiquement à la
porte des campus pour vous répondre
la parole est à mme à l'analyse de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur aux olias vous pointez
effectivement la difficulté que
rencontrent certains étudiants et je
voudrais vous rappeler comme j'ai pu le
faire la semaine dernière l'ensemble des
dispositifs qui ont été pris pour les
étudiants et notamment sur les questions
alimentaires et d'autres sujets qui
seront abordés dans les prochains jours
toujours avec eux toujours au plus près
du terrain toujours pour regarder ce
dont ils ont le plus besoin
là où je ne veux pas vous rejoindre
monsieur le sénateur c'est que vous
dites les étudiants sont exclues de ce
qui est prévu par le gouvernement dans
un jeune une solution pas du tout les
étudiants font partie de cette catégorie
plus large
vous parlez d vous parlez des étudiants
en apprentissage va bien sûr que ils
sont comme tous les apprentis vous
parlez des jeunes en contrats de
professionnalisation bien sûr qu'ils
sont comme tous les jeunes salariés bien
sûr que nous continuerons à accompagner
les jeunes diplômés c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle nous avons pu
avoir un taux d'embauché des jeunes
diplômés en cdi ou en cdd depuis deux
trois mois quasiment équivalent en 2020
qu'en 2018 et en 2019
alors monsieur le sénateur on ne peut
pas dire que les étudiants soient exclus
de la politique du gouvernement et non
et non
vraiment pas et d'ailleurs vous vous
voyez peut-être les files d'attentes
mois il se trouve que j'y vais et que et
et oui eh bien vous voyez dans ses fils
dans ces files d'attentes qui font dans
ces files d'attentes qui font selon vous
tellement polémique
qu'est ce que l'on voit et bien on voit
notamment des jeunes on voit notamment
des étudiants internationaux c'est pour
ça que nous avons doublé les aides à
destination de l'ensemble des étudiants
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus
d'un million et demi de repas un euro
qui sont servis dans les établissements
c'est pour ça que nous avons et nous
continuerons à soutenir l'ensemble des
jeunes et les étudiants aient compris
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous n'avez répondu à aucune de
mes trois questions
peut-être que vous pourriez demander au
cnrs de lancer une enquête sur ce sujet
madame la ministre 40% des étudiants
qu'ils pouvaient revenir les universités
ne l'ont pas fait et vous considérez que
c'est parce qu'ils préfèrent
l'enseignement à distance
je crains qu'ils ne reviennent jamais à
l'université pour éviter ce désastre
c'est maintenant que le gouvernement
doit agir
la parole ça me frôlent collègue
frédéric marchand pour le grand
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
aujourd'hui 10% du produit intérieur
brut et près de 2 millions et demi de
salariés
pour la seule région des hautes france
dont je suis issue ce sont 180 mille
emplois salariés plus de onze mille huit
cents établissements employeurs voilà
pour les chiffres
toutes ces entreprises elles ont un
grand potentiel d'innovation car elles
sont entrés nous le savons dans le
territoire et sont de parfaites réponse
aux besoins aux opportunités qu'il
s'agisse de l'urgence sanitaire de
l'urgence alimentaire éducatives ou tout
simplement citoyenne des solutions
innovantes ont depuis plusieurs mois
était trouvée par toutes les
coopératives et les entreprises sociales
dans notre pays en coopération avec les
autorités locales
oui la crise actuelle souligne autant la
nécessité des acteurs de la solidarité
aujourd'hui que le besoin de transformer
le modèle économique en s'inspirant des
pratiques et des valeurs de le ss demain
dans l'afrique au vide il sera
nécessaire de promouvoir la coopération
en offrant les services de base d'une
manière différente en rétablissant et en
créant des emplois décents grâce à des
modèles d'organisation de la production
divers et complémentaires
mais aujourd'hui madame administre le
monde de le s s est fortement secoué par
la crise du comique 19 et nombre de ces
structures durement impactée par la
crise auront bien du mal à se relever il
ya urgence à sauver ce secteur et
notamment toutes les petites structures
que nous connaissons bien sur nos
territoires qui font assaut
d'imagination de volontarisme dans leurs
actions quotidiennes mais qui pour
nombre d'entre elles ont bien du mal à
maîtriser les arcanes des dispositifs
déployés par le gouvernement
l'urgence est là madame la ministre et
je sais que vous y êtes particulièrement
sensible à l'aune de cette crise sans
précédent la question sera donc simple
quelles mesures mises en place
aujourd'hui pour sauver le soldat ss
merci pour vos réponses
andres la parole et à la secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable madame olivier
grégoire vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur marchand vous l'avais dit je
repartirai de votre question il y a
urgence
oui il y a urgence pour les entreprises
les structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire ess et l'intégralité du
gouvernement qui est aux côtés de ses
structures d'économie sociale et
solidaire comme tous les acteurs vous
l'avez dit économique
elles ont été frappées de plein fouet
elle aussi par la crise mais comme
possible de nombreux acteurs de la
solidarité que vous avez mentionné elles
sont particulièrement sollicités face à
cette crise sanitaire
elles ont des fragilités inhérentes à
leur modèle fragilité en matière de
trésorerie fragilité en matière de fonds
propres et c'est à l'ensemble de ses
fragilités que nous nous attelons dans
l'urgence et ce depuis plusieurs mois
vous l'avez dit aussi notre fléau le
fléau du gouvernement mais le cléo des
élus c'est le non recours le non recours
aux aides qui sont mises à disposition
pour ces structures de le ss c'est
pourquoi au-delà de leur dire à quoi
elles ont droit je m'attèle vraiment à
leur expliquer comment y parvenir
vous me permettrez mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs à cet endroit de citer le
guichet unique urgence tirait le ss
point fr qui permet à nos associations à
nos structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire jusqu'à 10 salariés de
bénéficier d'une aide directe d'une
subvention jusqu'à 5000 euros pour les
structures de une à trois salariés
jusqu'à 8000 euros pour les structures
de 4 à 10 salariés au delà de ça le
gouvernement a aussi je tenais à le
rappeler augmenté de quasiment 30% le
dispositif local d'accompagnement pour
faire en sorte que les structures soient
aussi accompagner et puissent mieux
répondre aux appels à projets du plan de
relance 1,3 milliard d'euros au sein du
plan de relance pour venir directement
servir les structures de l'économie
sociale et solidaire je souhaitais vous
dire que ce fonds urgent css de 30
millions d'euros a été lancé
bien entendu avec l'accord du premier
ministre il soutien de bruno le maire le
vin
en janvier dernier au 9 février nous
avions 5291 demandes qui sont en cours
d'instruction en quinze jours les fonds
sont développées ça ne sera peut-être
pas assez
partout il y aura il ya un besoin nous
essayons d'apporter une solution et je
serai dans le nord vendredi pour écouter
les structures de le ss qui en ont
besoin et les accompagner plus merci
monsieur le sénateur monsieur marchand a
parlé entre collègues éric kerrouche sur
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
comme vous le savez en plein milieu de
la pandémie le centre hospitalier de dax
côte d'argent a été victime la semaine
dernière d'une cyberattaque massive de
son système informatique
alors même que celui-ci était conforme
aux exigences réglementaires du
programme open
de telles attaques sont désormais trop
banal à dax pour illustrer les médecins
n'avaient plus accès à l'historique des
dossiers des patients
les calculs de doses pour la
chimiothérapie n'était plus possible
cela a nécessité de faire ses calculs à
la main limitant la capacité de
traitement quotidienne même si le
fonctionnement était sous-optimale j'ai
été impressionné lors de ma visite par
l'engagement sans faille de l'ensemble
des agents qu'il faut saluer toutes les
équipes se sont mobilisées
consciente de l'urgence d'assurer le
maintien du service public
c'est ce qui a permis de réduire les
pertes de chance pour les patients la
professionalisation de ces attaques
comme des attaquants sont des faits
incontestables
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes informatiques l'anssi
s'il ya une augmentation de 2 155% de ce
type d'attaquants 2020 le secteur de la
santé est particulièrement touchée le
chu de bordeaux reçoit ainsi 20 cyber
attaques par jour
cette cybercriminalité est à la hauteur
de ce qu'elle peut rapporter les
demandes de rançons varie entre 200
milles et 10 millions de dollars en
parallèle les coûts en matériel et en
personnel dédié sont de plus en plus
importante pour les structures privées
comme pour les sur les structures
publiques cette situation rapidement
décrit tu m'amènes monsieur le ministre
à plusieurs questions
localement d'abord si la rs est longue
si ont tout de suite été au chevet de
l'hôpital de dax
celui ci mettra du temps à récupérer
pouvez-vous me garantir son
accompagnement vers un retour à la
normale y compris s'agissant des
répercussions financières engendrées par
la tac
deuxièmement comptez-vous accroître les
moyens de landecy et selon quelles
modalités
et enfin en raison du caractère
extraterritorial de ces attaques
la france va-t-elle favoriser la
coopération européenne par exemple en
donnant plus de moyens à la nisa qui est
le pendant de longues files au niveau
européen je vous remercie pour vous
répondre
la parole est en charge de la transition
numérique de des communications
électroniques monsieur oh oui merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur cas où je vous
l'avais dit la france est sous la menace
des attaques informatiques
c'est le cas de notre pays c'est le cas
d'autres pays je pense par exemple à
l'attaqué qui a touché 4 100 hôpitaux
américains
fin novembre
2020 en france c'est l'ensemble de notre
économie l'ensemble de notre société qui
est sous la menace
on parle des hôpitaux jusque pour que
l'on se rende compte il y a eu 27
attaques majeures d'hôpitaux en 2020 il
y en a une par semaine depuis 2021 et je
veux saluer d'ailleurs à la fois le
travail des équipes hospitalières vous
l'avez fait le travail des agents de
l'ansea qui dès le 9 février dernier
sont allés sur place à l'hôpital de dax
il y a deux jours se sont rendus à
villefranche sur saône où je serai dans
quelques jours pour aider les hôpitaux à
faire face à la menace
alors face à cette menace la france et
ses partenaires sont mobilisés je le
rappelle ce que nous rappeler ce que
nous faisons les effectifs de 26 voulez
vous l'évoquiez augmenté de 200
personnes
depuis 2007 nous avons accompagné les
cent dix plus gros hôpitaux français
dans des audits de sécurité onze d'entre
eux sont accompagnés au jour le jour
nous travaillons à faire en sorte
d'augmenter la sensibilisation des
hôpitaux mais aussi des collectivités
territoriales on sait que la ville d'où
il a été attaqué dernièrement et de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens c'est une
menace à laquelle nous devons faire face
le président de la république devrait
dans les heures qui viennent prendre la
parole sur ce sujet pour nous amener à
franchir encore un cap dans cette
préparation et dans l'augmentation de la
vigilance de l'ensemble de l'économie et
de la société
enfin sur la réponse judiciaire je
voudrais souligner deux succès récents
les ce contre les cybercriminels 10 et
motets pays grigor qui ont été arrêtés
la semaine dernière grâce à une
coopération entre les services français
la justice française la justice
américaine et aussi nos partenaires
européens
le groupe y gorce et celui qui a attaqué
le journal ouest france fin novembre il
y a donc une réponse extrêmement forte
de l'état mais nous devons continuer à
mieux nous mobiliser et à mieux prévenir
ce genre de danger
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue christian bilhac pour le gros
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président maintenant
la ministre bientôt un an que nous
vivons avec le virus et avec les mesures
prises par le gouvernement pour lutter
contre la pandémie
cette énergie on va modifier en
profondeur les habitudes de nos
concitoyens et cela n'a pas épargné le
secteur du loisir qu'il soit sportif ou
culturel
de multiples activités étaient proposées
auparavant partout en france
parfois par des entreprises privées mais
le plus souvent par les communes ou par
les associations
chacun ici connaît et reconnaît le
formidable travail de ses bénévoles
associatifs trop tôt nombreux portant
souvent à bout de bras leurs structures
sacrifia leurs loisirs et la vie de
famille avec la fermeture au public des
lieux de pratique les adhérents se sont
tournés vers d'autres activités plus
individuelles y compris vers des
supports informatiques numériques
certains ont demandé le remboursement
des cotisations métal les associations
en difficulté financière le nombre de
dirigeants associatifs sont à bout de
souffle et pas abandonner les animateurs
sont désemparés inquiet et s'interrogent
sur leur avenir
demain la fanfare ou la peña reprendre
opel après des mois d'inactivité l'école
de musique ou le clip de théâtre vont
ils redémarrent et d'associations
sportives retrouvera-t-elle ses
adhérents les moyens financiers seront
ils suffisants pour poursuivre autant de
questions qui inquiètent dans nos
villages ruraux comme dans nos quartiers
urbains toutes ces activités madame le
ministre sont le ciment de notre société
elle crée du lien social et du vivre
ensemble on en le parlement débat du
séparatisme
nous sommes plus que jamais conscients
de leur vessie cité la ministre je
souhaite c'est à savoir si vous partagez
ces inquiétudes et quelles mesures vous
envisagez pour permettre à cette
structure
toutes différentes mais toutes
nécessaire de ne pas disparaître pour
vous répondre la parole à la secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'économie
sociale solidaire et responsable vous
avez la parole monsieur le sénateur bill
aka la question le gouvernement
partage-t-il l'intégralité de la
préoccupation concernant nos
associations la réponse est oui et trois
fois oui je me rappelais en vous
écoutant cette phrase de victor hugo le
mois des grandes âmes un temps toujours
à se faire
collectif et je sais si nos associations
qu'elles aient des bénévoles ou qu'elle
soit employeuse sont définitivement au
service de notre collectif et le
gouvernement dans son ensemble et
collectivement accompagne les
associations les accompagnent comment
avec d'abord et avant tout des mesures
je dirais génériques
j'en ai dit un mot le fonds d'urgence de
30 millions d'euros que je viens de
mentionner mais aussi un appui de 85
millions d'euros pour venir renforcer
les fonds propres de nos associations
avec la banque des territoires s'est
porté par ma collègue sara et l'aillerie
mais aussi le renforcement vous le savez
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs du
fonds de développement de la vie
associative avec 5 millions d'euros de
plus voter en plf en fin d'année
dernière ainsi que 30 % d'augmentation
du dispositif local d'accompagnement
outil précieux pour nos associations et
d'une communication que nous portons
tous pour leur faire connaître ces
dispositions et kehl j ai recours mais
aussi une aide sectorielle porté par mes
collègues et l'ensemble du gouvernement
je pense notamment bien entendu aux 60
millions d'euros consacrés aux
associations culturelles organisatrice
du festival de théâtre que des fonds
avec coeur et engagement roselyne
bachelot vous le savez mais à la hausse
aussi des 15 millions d'euros des
crédits fonjep pour les associations de
soutien à la jeunesse ou encore au sport
avec le fonds territorial de solidarité
de 15 millions d'euros là aussi qui
vient s'ajouter aux 120 millions d'euros
de soutien au sport dans le plan de
relance mais la russie
monsieur le sénateur ça n'est
qu'ensemble que nous parviendrons à
combattre le non recours il est
indispensable que nous portons ensemble
ces mesures sur les territoires pour
vous témoigner s'il le fallait encore de
l'investissement total du gouvernement
au service des associations nous aurons
très prochainement aux côtés du premier
ministre jean castex l'occasion avec ma
collègue sara et l'oeil
de recevoir les représentants de
l'univers associatif de les écouter mais
surtout de continuer à les accompagner
et s'il le faut encore plus je veux bien
que vous avez quelques secondes
merci madame la ministre j'espère que
tous ces arguments n'auront convaincu
les bénévoles du secteur associatif
permettez moi d'en douter un autre
collègue guy benarroch pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires tu
avais la parole lorsqu'il fait président
ma question s'adresser au ministère au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
sur la méga centrale biomasse de
gardanne dans les bouches du rhône
cette méga centrales biomasse s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une reconversion à la
biomasse de la troche 4 de la centrale à
charbon de chrome os situé sur les
communes de meyreuil et de gardanne
depuis l'annoncé de la fermeture de la
tranche 5 charbon d'ici 2022
l'état tente de mettre en place un pacte
de territoire pour l'avenir du site
industriel qui inclurait la méga
centrale et des projets classés seveso
en plein coeur d'une zone urbanisée
depuis 2010 est après l'accord conclu
entre l'état et une hyper l'industriel
repreneur s'est engagé à fournir 7500
heures d'électricité par an que l'état
rachètera trois fois le prix du marché
ceci ne pourrait-il pas s'apparenter
elle subventionne des 10es de 1 milliard
d'euros pendant la durée du contrat
ce site rockot des difficultés
techniques pour fonctionner au delà des
mouvements de grève connu par le passé
l'industriel ne remplit toujours pas ses
obligations en matière de fourniture de
kilowattheures 2021
l'état ne semble pas s'en inquiéter nous
remettons pas en question ce contrat
voire même abandonnerait les indemnités
que l'industriel aurait dû payer pour
non respect des engagements contractuels
aussi j'aimerais savoir si le
gouvernement contre ordre public
les conditions de ce contrat qu'il le
semble pas vouloir offre malgré tous les
éléments que je vient d'apporter pour
vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre
transition écologique la même pompili
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs benarroch comme vous
le signalez le président de la
république s'est engagé à fermer les
dernières centrales à charbon d'ici 2022
c'est un pas important sur le plan
écologique nous économiserons ainsi
l'équivalent des rejets de co2 de 4
millions de véhicules
bien sûr la fermeture des centrales
implique de donner aux territoires
concernés de nouvelles perspectives de
développement et nous faisons main dans
la main avec les collectivités avec les
partenaires sociaux les associations à
travers les pactes territoriaux
vous citez la centrale de gardanne vous
me n'y aurait pas que cette décision de
politique énergétique que vous soutenez
n'est pas aisée à mettre en oeuvre
disons le d emplois sont supprimés sur
la centrale mais aussi auprès des
sous-traitants et sur le port sur le
grand port de marseille fos et c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire sur le
territoire de gardanne c'est pourquoi
nous avons apporté des solutions
complémentaires à travers des crédits
supplémentaires de l'état et un
accompagnement social renforcé des
salariés
enfin nous n'avons pas souhaité ajouter
de la difficulté aux difficultés
en effet la centrale de gardanne
meyreuil compte une tranche biomasse
autorisé il ya près de 10 ans maintenant
par le gouvernement de l'époque le
contrat de rachat d'énergie produite
suis un mécanisme classique qui
correspondait à l'ancienne politique de
soutien l'électricité produite à partir
de biomasse
alors ce n'est pas une spécificité de
gardanne puisque plusieurs dizaine de
lauréats ont été désignés entre 2005 et
2010 9 à l'issue d'un appel d'offres le
contrat de rachat prévoit en effet des
pénalités si l'installation n'atteint
pas une disponibilité minimale mais dans
le cas de gardanne il a été jugé que la
longueur l'ampleur et les causes de la
grève qui a paralysé le site ces
dernières années justifier de ne pas les
appliquer pour les années 2010 8 à 2020
ce qui explique le cas que vous
soulignez tubes et laroche mais je vous
remercie madame la ministre de répondre
à cette question posée au ministre de
l'économie et des finances je vous ai
également posé une question écrite
toujours sans réponse sur les problèmes
posés par les méga centrales biomasse
ottrott leur approvisionnement en bois
problèmes relayés d'ailleurs dans une
tribune du monde hier 6
ni par 500 scientifiques et experts
internationaux depuis cette centrale se
trouve dans un passé industriel à
l'avenir obscures avec les boues rouges
aux incidences écologiques préoccupe a
toujours accepté par votre gouvernement
et aux de vire économique incertain
après le rachat de l'usiné par une
entreprise guinéenne
j'attendais aujourd'hui une position du
gouvernement sur l'aspect concurrentiel
ou non de cette méga centrales biomasse
et des précisions sur un contrat qui
restent opaques
enfin j'aurais aimé apprendre du
gouvernement la réelle nature des
relations liant sa politique énergétique
au propriétaire le groupe ph du
milliardaire tchèque daniel crétine ski
acquéreur de nombreuses centrales
charbon en europe
intéressé par les rejoindra de l'ours le
lait subventionnée par l'état et par
ailleurs aux preneurs de nombreux médias
français
mais si la parole est à notre collègue
jean marc boyer pour le gonfler
république à monsieur le ministre de la
santé le ressenti le vécu de nos aînés
en ehpad et de leurs familles est
aujourd'hui sans appel leur isolement
leur solitude sont mortifères pour de
nombreux résidents d'environnement
familial ou amical est le seul lien qui
les rattache au monde extérieur
est ce la raison essentielle de vivre
aussi coupé du contact de leurs proches
nos anciens vivent un calvaire qu'un
profond ressenti d'enfermement avec les
contraintes imposées aux directeurs
d'ehpad
que signifie voir ses proches 20 minutes
tous les quinze jours et seulement deux
personnes à la fois vous souhaitez
protéger nos aînés mais à quel prix
est ce protégé de laisser mourir nos
aînés que ce sentiment d'abandon
au point que certains disent je préfère
mourir du coc vite que d'isolement
protéger c'est aussi le respect de la
dignité humaine des personnes âgées et
vulnérables
cette dignité dans la vie ne peut pas
être bafoués au motif de sauver des vies
protéger c'est aussi gérer la fin de vie
nous devons permettre à la famille
d'accompagner son parent jusqu'au bout
protéger c'est lutter contre le virus de
la solitude vieillir enfermé entraîne un
vrai risque de glissements et cela
jusqu'à la mort et que le refus brutal
de communiquer de s'alimenter de
recevoir des saints destitution un
pardon malgré le
vous m'en exemplaire des personnels
alors monsieur le ministre
le tout sanitaire n'at-il pas atteint sa
limite aujourd'hui quelles perspectives
et quelles solutions proposez-vous
pourrons pour cette situation mortifère
pour vous répondre la parole de l'état
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué en charge de l'autonomie vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean marc
boyer
je vous remercie de cette question qui
me permet d'aborder ce sujet éminemment
humain au delà du sanitaire évidemment
face à un virus qui nous était inconnu
vous en conviendrez et qui frappe et
notamment les personnes âgées de manière
virulente 80% des victimes sont des
personnes âgées
nous avons dû prendre des décisions
parfois difficiles dans la première
vague vous le savez lors de mes
déplacements de terrain j'ai pu
évidemment constaté comme vous avec le
retour du personnel des résidents de
leur famille
bien sûr le vécu dramatiques parfois et
les syndrome de glissement qui se sont
ajoutés ce virus nous ne connaissons pas
encore sous toutes ses variantes vous en
conviendrez force est de constater que
nous le connaissons mieux le personnel
le dit il se sent mieux aguerris pour le
prévenir pour protéger pour mieux
protéger et pour le dépister mano dès ma
nomination j'ai été saisi évidemment de
cette question profondément humaine au
delà du sanitaire j'ai donné des
orientations aux ehpad de suite pour
donner corps à une ligne de crête
fragile un principe clé protéger nos
aînés sans les isoler pas de directives
donc mais des lignes de conduite très
clair pour orienter orienter les
décisions des directeurs parce que ça
n'est jamais simple faire en sorte que
ces établissements ne soient pas démunis
non plus face au virus
ces orientations ont été adjointe de
test aussi pour permettre le test à
destination des professionnels de celles
et ceux qui leur rendent visite des très
prochainement grâce à l'arrivée des
tests salivaires qui seront moins
invasif aussi nous espérons que ces
pratiques s'en trouveront faciliter
aussi en concertation avec les acteurs
du secteur que j'ai toutes les semaines
par visioconférence toutes les
fédérations d pad jeu
j'ai mis en place des modes de visite
vous avez raison sur rendez-vous pour
mieux encadrer et pour assurer surtout
le maintien de ce lien social nécessaire
nous avons également demandé à ce que
les visites en fin de vie soit permise
bien sûr pour accompagner les aînés dans
leurs derniers instants
la vaccination enfin ouvre des
perspectives aujourd'hui puisque vous le
savez fin février 80 % des personnes
seront vaccinées en ehpad dans notre
pays
je pense que ça me permet de donner
l'occasion de saluer et saluer cet
engouement qui prouve qu'il fallait
prendre du temps explique et pour qu'on
retire le consentement et c'est fait
nous avons fait le choix aujourd'hui
peut saisir le haut conseil de santé
publique et le cos est d'obtenir
orientations de votre anti vaccinales
pour définir les modalités de visite les
plus adéquates dans le contexte de haute
couverture vaccinale merci de votre
équipe
monsieur boyer me protéger mais madame
la ministre
c'est aussi et surtout vacciner vous
l'avez dit mais les français le quorum
ne comprennent pas votre stratégie de
vaccination
pas d'anticipation dans les commandes
des vaccins des organisations des
centres de vaccination listes d'attentes
interminables
le président de la république a promis
que 50 millions d'adultes seraient
vaccinés fin août
aujourd'hui seulement 2,3 millions reçu
une dose 815 mille doses la réalité
malheureusement et que la france fait
partie des pays les moins avancés dans
la vaccination plutôt que de
l'autosatisfaction fait preuve
d'humilité et efficacité
merci la parole et ça nos collègues rémi
féraud pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre chers collègues la crise
sanitaire économique a encore accentué
les inégalités et la précarité et les
difficultés financières des plus
modestes
or pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
cette situation sociale est aggravée par
les pratiques des établissements
bancaires qui continuent
l'air de rien ne prélever chaque mois
leurs commissions diverses frais de
gestion et frais pour incidents de
paiement
après une légère baisse ces deux
dernières années le montant moyen des
frais bancaires est de nouveau à la
hausse
ces prélèvements ne correspondent
souvent aucun service concret concerne
la plupart des français et atteignent
une facture annuelle de 216 euros en
moyenne et souvent en réalité bien plus
pour ceux qui ont des difficultés
financières
la mécanique des frais bancaires est
ainsi une mécanique appauvrissante de
laquelle il est difficile voire parfois
impossible de s'extraire et ses frères
présentera une manne financière de 6 5
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour les banques somme estimée puisque
le chiffre n'est communiqué par aucune
banque y compris aux pouvoirs publics
qui ne dénonce même pas ce manque de
transparence
à plusieurs reprises le président de la
république et le gouvernement ont pris
des engagements mais sans jamais
renforcer le cadre légal existant sur
les frais bancaires
après le vote de notre proposition de
loi sur la limitation des frais ici même
au sénat l'an dernier vous vous êtes
contenté d'un timide décret en juin
dernier
aujourd'hui alors que la pauvreté
explose dans notre pays
l'urgence sociale exige que vous
n'attendiez plus pour protéger les
français de frais bancaires opaques
excessifs et injustes
ma question est donc simple allez vous
enfin agir pour mettre fin à ces abus
pour vos réponses
le rôle des états d'âme olivia grégoire
secrétaire d'état madame la ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur féroé vous l'avez mentionné
depuis 2018
je suis un engagement du président de la
république le ministre bruno lemaire
oeuvre pour la protection des publics
vulnérables contre les frais d'incidents
bancaires excessifs le gouvernement ni
accessoirement les parlementaires que
vous êtes mais aussi les députés aucun
n'aura attendu sa crise sanitaire pour
se brancher sur le sujet un plafonnement
depuis 2000 18 à 25 euros par mois de
tous les frais d'incidents pour les
clients fragiles s'ajoutent un
plafonnement à 20 euros par mois et 200
par an des frais d'incident pour les
bénéficiaires de l'offre spécifique
clients fragiles que les banques doivent
proposer à leurs clients en situation de
fragilité nous avons aussi obtenu des
banques qu'elles s'engagent à augmenter
de 30% le nombre de bénéficiaires de
cette offre spécifique engagements tenus
monsieur le sénateur féraud le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'offre spécifique a
augmenté de 33% entre 2017 et 2019 à
plus de 500 mille bénéficiaires d'autres
mesures protectrices ont été introduites
en 2020 notamment le plafonnement
automatique pour les publics à faibles
revenus qui connaîtraient des incidents
répétés ou en situation de
surendettement nous avons enfin
également exiger des établissements
bancaires
la pleine transparence sur leur
appréciation des publics fragiles et
depuis mai 2000 vent la banque de france
a mis en place une cellule d'alerté en
cas de difficultés rencontrées par un
particulier en matière d'inclusion
bancaire et d'applications de frais
bancaires
ainsi depuis 2010 est le gouvernement
mais aussi les parlementaires ont
davantage fait ensemble pour ses frais
d'incidents bancaires appliqués aux
publics fragiles qu'aucun gouvernement
auparavant plus que des engagements ce
sont ici des résultats en un mot en 2019
1,4 million de français avait déjà vu
leurs frais bancaires totaux réduit je
vous remercie
monsieur féraud merci madame la ministre
a rappelé les timides avancées qu'a fait
le gouvernement
mais moi je lui ai rappelé aussi tout ce
qu'il n'a pas fait et je constate avec
regret que la bonne volonté du
gouvernement est encore et toujours
moins grande que la mauvaise volonté des
banques
pendant ce temps ce sont les français
les plus modestes qui s'appauvrissent et
les frais bancaires qui augmente donc je
vous le redis encore
agissez et reprenez notre proposition de
loi adoptée ici au sénat la parole est
maintenant d'autres collègues stéphane
le rudulier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
j'aimerais revenir quelques instants sur
un sujet qui a déjà été évoqué
madame claire et donc ancien journaliste
nommé défenseur des droits
il ya peu par le président de la
république imagine suspendre les
contrôles d'identité dans certaines
zones en france car elle les juge selon
ses dires insupportable pour certains
jeunes
ainsi pour madame et dont l'état ne
pouvant pas lutter efficacement contre
la délinquance dans certains secteurs de
notre pays
il vaudrait mieux démissionner m son
coeur en bandoulière et créer un cadre
juridique spécifique afin d'assurer la
pleine sérénité de ce que la justice que
la police et la gendarmerie irrite et
dérange
pourquoi ne pas créer directement des
fans zone réservée aux délinquants et
entièrement sanctuary zay pour que les
honnêtes gens ni entre surtout pas
mais la violence la violente attaque des
forces de l'ordre par une bande de
jeunes à poissy aux cris de tuez les a
certainement fait vaciller les
certitudes de madame et dont on scie
face à ce tollé provoqué par sa
proposition la défenseur est revenu hier
sur ses dires tout en réaffirmant
cependant qu'il existe des contrôles
d'identité discriminatoires
cette position est surréaliste elle
incarne le pense est faux le renoncement
qui grande reine la france depuis de
trop nombreuses années
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
venez de clarifier la position du
gouvernement
mais au-delà de cette actualité pensez
vous réellement que le rôle du défenseur
des droits est de jeter l'opprobe de
lancer des anathèmes sur nos forces de
l'ordre déjà suffisamment attaqué et
prouvé ces derniers temps pour vous
répondre
la parole est aux milices de l'intérieur
monsieur d'hormones à monsieur le
président l'un des messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
évoqué la nomination de madame et donc
par le président de la république il est
normal en démocratie que lé président de
la république quel qu'il soit nos hommes
à des postes
parfois les gens qui viennent pas
toujours ce que pense la majorité
parlementaire
ceci serait d'ailleurs ont disons que
cette nomination est aussi validé par
les commissions parlementaires
compétentes
la deuxième des choses monsieur le
sénateur c'était pour évidemment
m'inscrire tout à fait dans les propos
de monsieur le premier ministre et que
si les propos de madame la défenseure
des droits lui appartiennent nous avons
d'ailleurs constaté qu'elle les avait un
peu corrigé
il est évident que le ministère de
l'intérieur ne mettra pas en place cette
expérimentation
il est évident que les contrôles
d'identité sont nécessaires que s'il ya
des abus il faut évidemment pouvoir les
sanctionner
mais que sur les 5 millions d'opérations
de police et de gendarmerie
chaque année 99 7 % de ces opérations
par des femmes et des hommes courageux
qui risquent leur vie tous les jours que
vous connaissez comme je les connais se
passe bien
aucun signalement source et 99 7% 2 5
millions d'opérations de police
et c'est bien connaître le travail de la
police que de le souligner et c'est mal
connaître le travail des forces de
l'ordre de ne pas voir que les contrôles
d'identité sont toujours faits soit sous
l'autorité du procureur de la république
et donc de l'autorité judiciaire soit
d'un officier de police judiciaire
soit deux policiers lorsqu'ils
constatent que à proximité il ya eu un
crime ou un délit
faisons confiance en nos forces de
l'ordre je crois que c'est le cas des
parlementaires la nation c'est le cas du
ministre de l'intérieur vous le savez
c'est le cas du gouvernement ces cas du
président de la république et c'est le
cas de l'immense majorité des français
qui n'attendent qu'une seule chose c'est
que les zones de droit soit partout sur
le territoire qu'est policiers soient
partout chez eux et que nous continuons
à vivre dans un moment où évidemment il
y aura moins de contrôle d'entités parce
qu'elle est tout simplement moins de
délinquance merci la parole est à notre
collègue pascal martin pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre des transports
elle porte sur l'articulation entre
défense de l'environnement et
développement des grandes
infrastructures en partant de l'exemple
du contournement est dormant en
septembre 2017
après quasiment 50 ans d'études la
région normandie de département de la
seine maritime que je présidais à
l'époque et la métropole rouen normandie
ont conclu un accord pour boucler le
financement du contournement est de
l'agglomération rouennaise cette
indispensable rond et la seule métropole
de france de cette taille plus de 500000
habitants à ne pas bénéficier
aujourd'hui d'une telle infrastructure
or le 8 février dernier le nouveau
président de la métropole a décidé d'y
renoncer sous la pression de ses alliés
écologistes un véritable électrochoc la
région et le département ont donc pris
l'engagement d'accroître leurs
participations financières pour couvrir
le renoncement de la métropole sur
ministre l'état est le maître d'ouvragé
de cette infrastructure
la réalisation du projet était soumis
jusqu'à là à la participation de toutes
les collectivités concernées l'état
va-t-il y renoncer parce que la
métropole sont des retirer ou bien
va-t-il aller jusqu'au bout d'un
engagement que le conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures et la loi
d'orientation des mobilités on
l'identifié comme figurant parmi les
plus importants pour le développement de
notre pays
plus globalement l'exemple rouennais
pose la question de l'articulation entre
infrastructures et protection de la
nature
on ne peut pas opposer les deux par
principe en l'occurrence un
contournement fluide génère moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qu'un engorgement urbain permanent sans
même parler de l'aspect sanitaire du
problème car la qualité de l'air s'en
ressent pour les habitants monsieur le
ministre
l'inscription de la protection de la
biodiversité dans la constitution nous
permettra-t-il de continuer de pouvoir
faire à l'avenir les bons choix de
manière pragmatique sans le cdl
quelconque idéologie je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
base de la transition écologique
merci monsieur le président monsieur
sénateurs martin vous m'interrogez sur
ce projet de contournement est de rouen
qui consiste en un tracé neuf de 40 km
destiné à relier les autoroutes a28 et
a13
afin de décongestionner la métropole
rennaise il s'agit d'un projet
effectivement anciens vous l'avez dit
qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses
concertations depuis plus de dix ans les
mêmes des décennies 50 ans me dit vous
la dupe a été délivré le 14 novembre
2017 après un avis favorable du conseil
d'état les collectivités parties
prenantes la métropole de rouen
à l'époque le département de
seine-maritime et la région normandie
avait quant à elle confirmé leur
engagement financier en 2017 pour 50 %
de la subvention d'équilibré l'état
devait prendre en charge l'autre moitié
du financement tels qu'inscrits
effectivement dans la loi d'orientation
des mobilités néanmoins comme vous le
mentionnez d'importants débats sont
apparues lors des élections municipales
de 2001 à rouen au regard des enjeux
généraux de protection de
l'environnement et des besoins des
habitants qu'il s'agit évidemment de
concilier et nous partageons tous ce
point de vue monsieur le préfet de
région avait alors demandé aux
collectivités de confirmer leur
intention le département et la région
ont renouvelé leur soutien quand la
métropole a fait part de son
désengagement financier de l'opération
et proposer d'autres alternatives
nous avons bien pris note du souhait par
la région et de département de prendre
en charge les 66 millions d'euros
initialement dévolue à la métropole nous
suivons avec une attention particulière
ce dossier mais nous ne souhaitons pas
avancé contre les collectivités locales
nous tenons à un débat apaisé sur le
sujet est réaliste quant aux
problématiques notamment en matière de
trafic aujourd'hui rencontré au sein de
ce territoire et donc nous en appelons
au dialogue entre les parties prenantes
et sommes prêts à étudier sérieusement
toutes les propositions qui sont
soumises pour faire en sorte de
concilier ces deux
ces deux nécessité absolue qui sont la
mobilité des habitants de la métropole
et des gens qui la traverse est aussi la
protection de l'environnement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
bernard fournier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues de vie
maintenant huit ans nos forces armées
sont déployées ou celle le courage
l'abnégation et la compétence de l'eau
soldats ont permis d'y remporter de
nombreux succès militaires et d'empêcher
la constitution d'un sanctuaire
islamistes les défis à relever restent
cependant considérable face à un ennemi
toujours dangereux et en perpétuelle
mutation
nos armées devront en permanence adapter
leur dispositif opérationnel mais aussi
pouvoir s'appuyer sur une montée en
puissance des forces armées de nos
partenaires pour contrer efficacement la
menace face à un ennemi qui se nourrit
aussi des fragilités des défaillances
des états de la région la paix et la
sécurité
nous pourrons remettre à la seule faveur
d'une action militaire
les conditions de cette renaissance sont
aussi économiques et politiques
ce n'est qu'en progressant sur cette
voie que pour être durablement
consolider les acquis de l'opération et
conjurer la tentation d'en haut très
précipitée qui ruinerait tous les
efforts et les sacrifices consentis
monsieur le drian avait déclaré dans cet
hémicycle lors du décès récent débat sur
le bilan et les perspectives de barkan
demandé par nos tristes élan collègues
le président christian combes au que le
sommet de djamena devait être le sommet
du sursaut diplomatique du sursaut
politique et du sursaut du développement
ils sont en effet indispensables pour
redonner des perspectives et d'une
certaine manière du sens à l'engagement
de nos troupes sur le terrain monsieur
le ministre quel ont été lors de ce
sommet les messages adressés par le
président de la république à nos
partenaires et estimez vous qu'il est
permis de provoquer ces sursauts que
vous appelez de vos voeux je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur clément bonne secrétaire d'état
en charge du chantier européenne
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fournier je veux d'abord comme
vous rendre hommage au courage de nos
troupes qui assure depuis plusieurs
années désormais la sécurité de la
france et de l'europe
le président de la république a
participé au sommet du g5 celles se met
de ne jamais n'a par visioconférence au
début de la semaine lundi et mardi et à
une session élargie à cette coalition
pour internationale pour le celle qui a
été mise en place il ya quelques mois à
l'issue du sommet de peau et qui
regroupe aujourd'hui 45 partenaires
internationaux comme vous l'avez
souligné il était temps de faire le
point sur ses engagements et d'amplifier
la dynamique engagée le prendre la
république a eu l'occasion de le dire
publiquement le sommet de n'djamena a
permis de faire ce bilan d'enregistrer
des résultats et des réussites dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et le
président a ainsi indiqué un stand de
points très concrets qui sont les
résultats de ce sommet de suivi d'abord
le déploiement d'un bâtiment d'un
bataillon pardon aux tchadiens dans la
zone des trois frontières pour amplifier
l'effort militaire de nos partenaires
continuer et amplifier la lutte contre
le haut commandement du j'estime et de
l'état islamique au grand sahara la
poursuite de du financement de la force
conjointe du g5 celle notamment en
amplifiant les financements européens et
puis la mise en place c'est l'engagement
qu'a porté la ministre des armées
florence parly 2 la montée en puissance
de la force européenne takouba où près
de 10 partenaires européens nous ont
rejoints compte tenu que cet aliment
politiques et militaires de cette
implication accrue de nos partenaires
africains et européens
le prince la république a indiqué que
nous mentrel maintien drion notre effort
militaire et que si des évolutions
devaient être apportées nous les
examinons riom en temps voulu après l'
amplification de cette dynamique le
sommet de n'djamena donc permis de poser
les jalons de ce sursaut que jean yves
le drian avait évoqué politique et de
développement en particulier sursaut
politique par la relance de la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord d'alger
sur la question du nord-mali et sursaut
de développement au moment même où le
parlement commence l'examen jean yves le
drian sur à l'assemblée nationale
assemblée nationale dès cet après-midi
de notre loi sur le développement pour
permettre le retour des services aux
populations dans les zones qui sont
libérés par l'action militaire nous
poursuivrons avec un sommet au mois de
mars le suivi des engagements pris lors
du sommet de pau ma parole est qu un
autre collègue claudine lepage fond le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
un peu partout sur le territoire
l'inquiétude et même la colère des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves du
second degré gronde en cause les
discussions autour de la dotation
horaire globale qui doit acter de votre
choix budgétaires de supprimer 1800
emplois d'enseignants dans le second
degré ce choix amène de nombreux
établissements à préparer la rentrée
scolaire dans des conditions intenables
alors que votre gouvernement programme à
l'ong proclame pardon à longueur
d'interviews la priorité donnée à la
jeunesse cette mesure va avoir des
conséquences désastreuses sur la qualité
des enseignements classes surchargées
restriction des choix d'enseignement
recours trop importants aux heures
supplémentaires réduction du nombre de
professeurs remplaçants et cetera notre
jeunesse
durement touché par les conséquences de
l'épidémie de lakovic 19 va être la
victime collatérale de ces suppressions
de postes
incompréhensible incompréhensible car la
situation sanitaire devrait au contraire
nous conduire à recruter davantage
d'enseignants pour diminuer le nombre
d'élèves par classe et mieux les
encadrer
incompréhensible car la réforme du lycée
que vous avez souhaité
nécessite des moyens en terme d'heures
et de postes
monsieur le ministre le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
vous avez déjà alerté sur les
conséquences que vos choix budgétaire
allait avoir sur le terrain mais il
n'est jamais trop tard pour agir
monsieur le ministre allez vous entendre
la colère des enseignants et des parents
d'élèves et revenir sur votre décision
prévoir al'inverse des mesures
exceptionnelles d'accompagnement pour la
rentrée 2021
ce serait un premier signal important
envoyé aux enseignants aux parents et
tout particulièrement à notre jeunesse
pour vous répondre la parole est à mme
et celui de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur blanc
caire en grève et la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mais à madame la
sénatrice lepage vous aborder une
question qui est assez traditionnel à
cette période de l'année puisque c'est
le moment où les établissements
reçoivent leurs dotations horaires
globales
vous faites référence aussi à
l'enseignement secondaire pas à
l'enseignement primaire
probablement parce que vous reconnaissez
implicitement qu un effort budgétaire
considérable pour l'enseignement
primaire avec des créations de postes
beaucoup plus importante de 1600 c'est
tout à fait significatif et nous allons
avoir le meilleur taux d'encadrement
historique à l'école primaire c'est le
résultat d'un choix politique très fort
qui est la priorité à l'école primaire
disons le très clairement la france
dépensait jusque là moins que la moyenne
des pays de l'osce et de pour son
enseignement primaire et plus pour son
enseignement secondaire est ce que ça
veut dire pour autant que nous
sacrifions l'enseignement secondaire
la réponse est évidemment et non d'abord
en terme de taux d'encadrement il reste
le même parce que nous compensons les
éventuels poste qui part dans certains
établissements par des heures
supplémentaires ce qui au passage peut
se traduire par de l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat pour ceux qui prennent
ces heures supplémentaires
ensuite parce que nous avons toute une
série de dispositifs qui se voit dans le
budget qui a connu une augmentation
inédite 2 milliards près de 2 milliards
pour l'an prochain sur ce quinquennat
c'est 6 milliards d'euros en plus pour
l'éducation nationale ces deux milliards
d'euros sous le gouvernement que vous
souteniez précédemment donc ces moyens
ne sont pas donnés
indistincte ils sont donnés pour des
politiques qui vont vers les plus
défavorisés je pense notamment au
dispositif de voir fait au collège mais
c'est aussi l'ensemble des politiques
qui t'ont trait aux facteurs sociaux de
la réussite éducative par exemple les
sites et éducatives que nous menons avec
nadia cette politique publique est une
politique publique qualitative qui cible
les bénéficiaires en ciblant les plus
défavorisés ce n'est pas une politique
aveugle ce n'est pas une politique de
saupoudrage c'est une politique aussi
qui fait attention aux territoires
je pense en particulier aux territoires
ruraux qui font l'objet d'une attention
particulière
y compris dans le cadre du plan de
relance parce qu'en ce moment mais aussi
toute une série de bonnes nouvelles pour
les territoires je pense par exemple à
ceux qui en ce moment après leur leur
choix pour les internats d'excellence ou
encore ceux qui bénéficient du plan
informatique en zone rurale je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est un autre collègue à la
châtillon pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame la ministre de
l'écologie et des transports je voudrais
simplement vous dire que l'une de vos
prédécesseurs il y a dix ans m'avait
chargé d'établir un rapport sur le
devenir du canal du midi
ce rapport que j'avais alors déposé
proposer des modifications de
l'organisation et de la stratégie afin
de préparer la réhabilitation et
d'assurer la vie de ce grand site
historique patrimonial paysager est très
fortement touristique pour notre grande
région
l'arrivée du chancre coloré nous a dès
2010 oblige et effectivement les
abattages d'arbres importants et à des
investissements importants
toutefois la gestion globale de
l'ouvragé nous inquiète très fortement
aujourd'hui
en effet votre ministère a réduit de
façon drastique
depuis plusieurs années les crédits
dédiés au fonctionnement général à
l'emprunt d abord l'entretien des abords
et à l'environnement
le deuxième point c'est les responsables
en charge change très régulièrement
heureusement nous avons la chance
d'avoir nous avons la chance d'avoir un
préfet de région remarquable qui
s'occupe de nos dossiers
ce que j'aurais simplement vous dire
c'est que à ce jour nous avons de gros
problèmes de différence entre l'urbain
et le rural
quelles sont ces problèmes c'est tout
simplement que les nouvelles règles qui
s'imposent s'oppose au p lus au pelvis
au scot mais aussi à la dréal et à la
ddt il faut véritablement que vous
fassiez un effort important tant sur le
plan financier que sur le plan
organisationnel pour que nous ayons la
capacité de véritablement assurer
l'avenir du canal du midi
merci pour vous répondre monsieur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce président mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur châtillon
effectivement je revendique de très bien
connaître cet ouvrage magnifique qu'est
le canal du midi je vous le rappelle
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et je connais aussi les travaux
monsieur le sénateur que vous avez par
le passé conduit sur ce sujet très
important pour la région occitanie pour
la france pour son attractivité
historiques et par ma réponse je
voudrais simplement vous rassurer si
vous êtes inquiet de l'implication très
forte de l'état aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales non
seulement pour la sauvegarde mais
également pour la restauration et le
rayonnement de cet ouvrage historique
construit chacun le sait paris quai au
xviie siècle il est au coeur des
priorités de l'état et notamment de la
ministre de la transition écologique qui
aurait évidemment pu parfaitement vous
répondre puisque puisque vous le savez
il y a de l'irrigation
il y à du tourisme il y a des pistes
cyclables
nous allons également investir dans le
numérique le long du canal latéral
enfin vous savez tout cela par coeur vnf
voies navigables de france qui est en
l'espèce vous le savez également notre
opérateur
je veux vous rassurer sa dotation depuis
2019 a été augmenté d'un tiers et 75
millions sont prévus
globalement pour vnf dans le plan de
relance
s'agissant des investissements j'ai
signé avec la présence de région
occitanie il y a quelques semaines à
tarbes un accord de relance extrêmement
ambitieux qui s'agissant de l'état et
dans le prolongement des efforts
antérieurement consenti prévoit sur les
deux prochaines années
un investissement a dit
elle monsieur le sénateur de 25 millions
d'euros pour la restauration des
plantations la restauration des berges
et la fibre optique que j'ai évoqués je
voudrais souligner aussi si vous me
permettez la mobilisation je l' ai déjà
dit des collectivités territoriales dans
le cadre d'une entente que vous
connaissez et qui montre ce partenariat
territorial auquel le gouvernement et
votre serviteur sont particulièrement
attachés oui le canal du midi à un
avenir
oui il va contribuer au développement
économique écologique et touristique de
la région aquitaine
monsieur châtillon vous avez quelques
secondes
monsieur le premier ministre je ne peux
que vous remercier simplement vous
donner deux éléments concrets il y avait
25 salariés entre l'origine du canal du
midi en haut de la montagne noire et le
canal du midi lui-même sur 60 km
aujourd'hui ne sont plus que cinq
c'est le premier point on a transformé
des cols bleus en col blanc ceci étant
dit sur le fond je m'interroge à nouveau
sur le problème d'une équité entre le
rural et l'urbain
il faut qu'aujourd'hui on a donné un
certain nombre de terres agricoles 600
800 mètres on ne peut même pas stocker
certains produits agricoles et de
l'autre côté vers le se construire dans
les grandes villes des immeubles très
importante activité du canal du midi
nous souhaitons un juste équilibre entre
le rural et l'urbain
merci de votre compréhension la parole
est maintenant notre collègue d'achat
pour le
les règles du corps merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre en novembre
dernier avec mes collègues du grand test
nous vous faisions part de notre vive
préoccupation quant à la situation de
strasbourg siège du parlement européen
nous appelions à des actions fortes du
gouvernement pour défendre et conforter
la place de la capitale française de
l'union européenne
cela fait désormais un an qu aucune
session plénière du parlement européen
ne s'est tenu à strasbourg et nous
venons d'apprendre que la session de
mars ne s'y tiendra toujours pas
c'est une atteinte au traité européen et
au principe de l'europe polycentrique au
coeur même de l'idée européenne
la tenue des sessions plénières à
strasbourg ne saurait être optionnel et
la pandémie qui concerne aussi bien la
belgique que la france ne saurait plus
longtemps être un prétexte pour remettre
en cause la vocation européenne de
strasbourg
actuellement le format hybride des
sessions plénières et piloter n'ont pas
de piste reste beau mais depuis
bruxelles avec près de 350 à 450 députés
présents physiquement à bruxelles le
parlement européen a tenu vendredi
dernier depuis strasbourg un exercice de
simulation parlementaire rassemblant
plus de 2500 jeunes
preuve qu'il est parfaitement capable de
piloter en ligne un événement qui
dépasse le nombre des députés européens
aux sessions plénières fin janvier c'est
le conseil de l'europe qui a tenu en
présence physique et à distance son
assemblée parlementaire avec des élus
venus de 47 états membres
cette session s'est tenue dans de
parfaites conditions d'organisation ce
qui est possible pour le conseil de
l'europe doit l'être pour le parlement
européen
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
aviez indiqué votre total engagement
pour défendre la vocation européenne de
strasbourg
mais les paroles ne suffisent plus nous
ne pouvons plus assister passivement à
cette situation et se limiter à des
réactions à chaque remise en cause du
statut de strasbourg face à une
situation qui ne saurait perdurer
pouvez-vous nous
dire ce que compte faire votre
gouvernement pour permettre députés
européens de revenir enfin dans la
capitale européenne je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est aussi
facteur d'état chargé des affaires
européennes monsieur bonne
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice schalk je partage au nom du
gouvernement sous l'autorité du premier
ministre votre préoccupation et surtout
notre total engagement qui a été rappelé
par le prix dans la république lui-même
pour un retour le plus rapide possible
et cela n'a que trop duré les sessions
du parlement européen à leurs sièges
prévus par les traités qui se situe à
strasbourg la situation sanitaire pause
d'évidentes difficultés mais ne saurait
justifier ce type de comportement et
cette situation qui perdure jusqu'à la
session du mois de mars
nous continuerons pour être très concret
les démarches diplomatiques au plus haut
niveau auprès du président du parlement
européen david sassoli près ministre en
avait pris l'engagement répondant au
courrier que vous aviez forte avec un
certain nombre d'autres élus je
relaierai aussi ses messages encore dans
les prochains jours vous savez que la
situation est particulière pour le
parlement européen par rapport par
exemple l'assemblée parlementaire du
conseil de l'europe puisque il y à des
déplacements impliquées qui sont
beaucoup plus importants mais cela ne
saurait justifier une situation qui
n'est pas conforme au traité qui n'est
pas conforme aux intérêts nationaux et
qui n'est pas conforme à notre
conception d'une europe polycentrique
comme vous l'avez également défendu pour
être offensif sur ce sujet et montrer
tout l'engagement partagé et que nous
portons au statut de strasbourg nous
sommes en train de finaliser l'état les
collectivités territoriales à nouveau
contrat triennal strasbourg capitale
européenne qui verra les moyens
financiers augmentent et ceux de l'état
nous en avons pris l'engagement mais
aussi nous l'espérons bien ceux des
collectivités territoriales concernées
je tiendrai de nouveau dans les
prochains jours une réunion avec
l'ensemble des élus de tous bords
concernés par la situation de strasbourg
nous préparons aussi vous le savez la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et dans ce cadre c'est
l'instruction qui a donné le premier
ministre et que nous portons auprès de
tous les membres du gouvernent
avec jean yves le drian pour que
strasbourg soient valorisés dans le
cadre cette présidence cela le saurait
compenser des situations actuelles mais
c'est un renforcement de son statut de
capitale européenne pour que les
événements politiques ministérielles se
tiennent au maximum dans la capitale
européenne
vous savez également qu'un hommage sera
rendu au parlement européen au président
valéry giscard d'estaing dans les
prochaines semaines ce sera aussi
l'occasion de réaffirmer cette vocation
open le plus solennellement possible
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
milices merci ne vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu notez bien le mercredi 3 mars 2021
la séance est suspendue sera reprise à
16h03 pour la désignation des membres de
deux missions d'information et l'examen
de la proposition de loi visant à
améliorer le système de santé par la
confiance et la simplification
je vous remercie
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vous avez pu
les suivre en direct et en intégralité
sur public sénat et tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard salle des
conférences pour une première réaction
celle de philippe bas le sénateur les
républicains de la manchette à votre
micro alexandre pour revenir et bien sûr
le vote par anticipation proposée par le
gouvernement
hier par voie d'amendement effectivement
un vote par anticipation à l'élection
présidentielle un vote sur des machines
à voter et philippe bas vous avez
travaillé sur cette question et bien de
méthodes alternatives de vote notamment
en période de crise sanitaire sur le
fond est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce
vote par anticipation électronique voyez
on mélange un peu tout c'est pas un vote
électronique comme si vous alliez aller
sur internet votée depuis votre domicile
c'est sur les machines à voter dans un
bureau de vote du département dans une
grande ville où vous pourrez venir si
vous habitez à 50 kilomètres dans une
autre commune il faudra vous inscrire à
la vence et puis alors là vous votez
trois jours avant la fin de la campagne
si un événement le jeudi ou le vendredi
ou le samedi en pleine campagne vous
pourrez pas obtenir compte dans notre
vote
et puis il faudra garder cette machine à
voter cette espèce de coffre fort pour
que le résultat du vote soit transporté
dans votre commune en quelque sorte et
partout dans le département
ceci relève de la plus parfaite
improvisation on ne peut pas plaisanter
avec le code électoral parce que le code
électoral c'est la sécurité du vote
c'est la sincérité du vote et on ne peut
pas improviser un dispositif qui peut
potentiellement toucher des millions
d'électeurs comme ça en déposant petit
matin sans en parler avec l'assemblée
nationale sans en parler avec les partis
politiques sans en parler avec
l'association des maires qui vont devoir
gérer le scrutin à quelques mois d'une
élection présidentielle l'élection mère
de toutes les élections
un système qui n'a pas été suffisamment
concertée étudiées y compris sur le plan
constitutionnel le conseil d'état n'a
même pas été amenés à donner son avis
comprendrait que la représentation
nationale on veut faire un travail
sérieux on peut pas rentrer dans ce
sujet de cette manière là et donc nous
ôterons je crois unanimement contre et
ça permettra de clore cet épisode qui
est encore le signe d'une démarche
gouvernementale un peu chaotique
si nous avions voulu étudier ça à fond
nous aurions pu le faire mais de toute
façon le vote anticipé
ça pose une question démocratique très
grave
c'est à dire voter avant la fin de la
campagne imaginée alors à quoi sert
d'avoir une campagne qui se clôture
trois jours après donc pour vous sur la
question du vote par anticipation
eh bien ça pose un problème
constitutionnel démocratique problèmes
d'organisation problèmes démocratiques
problèmes constitutionnels problème de
concertation démocratique enfin il faut
qu'on s'entende sur les règles de base
de la démocratie
le gouvernement peut pas faire irruption
comme ça en plein débat parlementaire
portant sur d'autres questions pour
ouvrir ce débat dans des conditions
aussi acrobatiques et improvise dernière
question philippe bas sur ce qui s'est
passé durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité et les mots très forts du
premier ministre qu'il a dit il n'y aura
pas sous son gouvernement
deux zones sans contrôle d'identité
comme l'avait proposé la défenseur des
droits ça vous rassure ses propos du 1er
mai il était temps il a bien fait le
clore le débat
c'est pas parce que il n'ya qu'un petit
pourcentage de cas d'interpellation dans
les contrôles d'identité que ceux ci
sont inutiles parce que heureusement et
imaginez si dans 90% des contrôles
d'identité il fallait arrêter les gens
non ça prouve quand même que quand on va
faire ces contrôles d'identité aléatoire
on interroge de bons citoyens qui sont
tout à fait en règle qui veulent bien
apporter leur contribution à l'ordre
public en se soumettant à ces contrôles
et puis on trouve parmi lieu un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont des choses à
se reprocher et on ne peut pas laisser
se créer dans notre pays des zones de
non-droit c'est évident merci beaucoup
philippe bas d'avoir répondu à mes
questions c'est à gotham merci beaucoup
alexandre on va continuer c'est débrief
j'accueille sur ce plateau david
assouline bonjour je
ordinateurs socialiste de paris et
philippe dallier bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les républicains de seine saint
denis tout d'abord et bien votre avis
sur ce que vient de dire philippe bas
cette histoire de vote par anticipation
on a découvert donc il ya l'amendement
déposé par le gouvernement qui va dans
ce sens pour faire de ce dispositif pour
la prochaine présidentielle
c'est un peu chaotique nous dit philippe
bas philippe dallier on sait plus que
chaotique c'était extrêmement
surprenants après ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis les contests us des
contestations des résultats
votre par correspondance vote par
anticipation vote par machine
électronique quasiment tout a été
contestée alors que l'on sait que
certains pays met un malin plaisir à
essayer de déstabiliser mais véritable
démocratie justement en perturbant les
élections on ira utiliser des machines
électroniques pour mettre en place un
vote anticipé mais franchement mais qui
a eu cette idée mais faut-il lutter
contre l'abstention
ce que nous dit legault si un jour une
élection présidentielle se joue à 5000
ou à dix mille voix et qu'on met
utiliser des machines à voter qui sont
des boîtes noires dont personne ne peut
nous assurer au bout du compte qu'elles
ne seront jamais piraté
vous imaginez ce qui va se passer dont
je pense qu ils le jeu ne vaut pas la
chandelle
nous avons des procédures de vote c'est
dimanche de 8 heures à 20 heures tout le
monde peut se déplacer
le vote est garanti comme étant
confidentiel dans l'isoloir chacun fait
ce qu'il veut et je note d'ailleurs que
pour les élections présidentielles la
participation est généralement très
forte donc mettre sur la table une
proposition comme celle là un an
l'élection alors que sanaa était
travaillée par personne franchement
c'est de l'amateurisme le plus complet
je me demande quelle mouche a piqué
celui qui a fait cette proposition est
ce qu on est aussi dans un contexte
particulier david assouline celui de la
pandémie
on peut avoir des craintes sur l'idée
d'avoir trop de monde dans l'est dans
les isoloirs ou que des personnes ne
veulent pas forcément se déplacer ce
qu'on nous dit aussi ce contexte
particulier petit justifier d'avoir
recours à bien à des nouveaux processus
ce que je crois c'est qu'il ya deux
questions qu'on peut séparer la première
c'est la méthode la façon la forme et le
fond dix ans
nous on a proposé un débat là-dessus ici
avec des propositions elles étaient
munies à prendre et à laisser
ni à regarder de haut pour justement
lutter contre l'abstention et des donc
déjà pour essayer de le faire dans des
élections locales
rappelons que le corps social ils ont
fait une proposition pour le vote par
correspondance ou par votre collègue
éric kerrouche par exemple ce que je
veux dire c'est que la faire ça pour les
présidentielles alors que ya quelques
semaines il avait envoyé tous sortis un
débat plus profond y compris posée sous
local est bizarre donc sur la forme on
peut que se dire ou ce sont encore des
amateurs vraiment le culte du non
professionnalisme atteint ses limites
quand même parce que sont heureux pas
être des professionnels m'a fait un
moment donné quand on dirige le pays
font un peu sécurisé le pays 1
donc où c'est ça ou alors c'est une
c'est une manoeuvre quelqu'un s'est dit
tiens on va essayer de faire une
manoeuvre avec un but inavoué je ne sais
lequel quelle en serait l'objectif des
gens sérieux
je sais pas et je ne sais même pas ce
que je sais c'est que la manoeuvre au
moins sur la méthode c'est que quand on
fait un amendement comme ça sur une
question aussi importante ça passe pas
devant le conseil d'état et donc on
évite un certain nombre de barrages
constitutionnel qui seront là de toute
façon c'est à dire si on laissait passer
cet amendement c'est évident que le
conseil constitutionnel en la vraie ça
parce qu'il ya un an cela met à égalité
un principe d'égalité parce que
effectivement dans une élection
présidentielle majeur il peut y avoir
des événements très importants ou
internationaux ou nationaux dans les
trois jours avant le vote où les
français ont besoin de savoir ce que
pense le futur président parce que
quelques jours après c'est la personne
qui va présider ou
la femme ou l'homme et donc je trouve
comme mes collègues je crois qu'on est
unanime mais parce qu'au sénat on aime
le sérieux sur les questions de
constitutionnalité de loi de fabrication
de la loi c'est c'est pas sérieux c'est
de l'amateurisme
est ce qu'il y avait une manoeuvre
derrière je n'en sais rien mais bon
félicité michel rocard qui disait que
face à des cas de figure comme celui a
souvent on imagine un complot mais dans
l'immense majorité des cas c'est une
connerie c'est ce que disait rocard
pense qu'on est plutôt dans la seconde
hypothèse
elle est en fait tout de suite soeur y
compris sur la question de l'abstention
si on pense parce que sa soeur sur un
moment où avec la pandémie aux est enfin
là c'est la présidentielle qui aura lieu
dans plus d'un an
par contre on se pose pas la question
sur les régionales comment ça va se
passer je vois aucune cohérence dans
cette proposition mais on comprend qu'il
ya en tout cas un refus en bloc de la
droite et de la gauche au sénat tout de
suite et bien on va rejoindre jean
macias et notre streamer politique qui a
suivi toute cette séance est bien avec
toute sa communauté sur la plateforme
twitch gens qu'est-ce qui a marqué les
uns et les autres lors de cette séance
aujourd'hui on écoute tams qui a marqué
aujourd'hui les les internautes ce sont
les questions qui ont été posées sur la
déclaration de claire et dont la
nouvelle défenseur des droits depuis
l'été dernier seulement qui a déclaré
qu'il fallait créer des zones sans
contrôle policier et les rares sénateurs
qui ont abordé cette question dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui ont été unanimes
pour eux c'est insupportable c'est
intolérable ce qu'elle a dit ce n'est
pas entendable et le gouvernement a
abondé dans son sens on a entendu jean
castex se lever en répondant en trois
phrases que non ça n'existerait jamais
des zones sans contrôle policier
il a répondu ça à dany wattebled et plus
tard stéphane le rudulier le sénateur
l'est républicain a lui aussi obtenu une
réponse similaire de la part de gérald
darmanin ce qui est un petit peu dérangé
les internautes dans ces échanges c'est
qu'à aucun moment ni les sénateurs ni le
gouvernement n'a parlé du sujet de fond
qui étaient abordés par claire et donc
qui est celui des contrôles au faciès et
des discriminations dans la police même
emmanuel macron avait reconnu dans son
interview sur brut à l'automne dernier
que ça existait et là ça a été un moment
où c'est vrai faut reconnaître que les
internautes se sont sentis papa très
représentée par les sénateurs qui n'ont
pas abordé ce sujet là le sujet central
sur le donc ça a été un petit peu
déceptif pour eux je ne te cache je ne
le cache pas l'autre sujet qui a été
abordé et qui est ce qui a séduit les
étudiants c'est la question de la cité
de la précarité des étudiants
la précarité des étudiants qui a été
abordé dans l'hémicycle par le sénateur
pierre ouzoulias ce la réponse de
frédéric vidal elle était compliquée la
réponse de faire des vidals parce que
fred vidal un vrai problème de
crédibilité du point de vue des
internautes
ils sont nombreux à vraiment plus
pouvoir l'entendre si je vais te le dire
comme ça c'est assez simple effet
riguidel et décribiliser notamment avec
la polémique ces derniers jours sur l'
enquête qu'elle a lancée sur la
recherche sur les chercheurs et sur
l'islamo gauchisme beaucoup
d'internautes trouve que ça tape
complètement à côté qui a une vraie
situation
encore une fois précarité et que là ils
auraient bien voulu entendre le
gouvernement à nouveau se saisir de ce
sujet là donc voila un petit peu les
réactions des internautes aujourd'hui
tam il ya merci merci beaucoup jean
beaucoup de choses dans ce que tu viens
de nous dire et qu'on va essayer de
débriefer on va tout d'abord parler et
bien de cette question de l'islamo
gauchisme qui a donc été abordé mais
plutôt des tours de la réplique de
pierre rose oulias tout à l'heure david
assouline donc frédéric vidal demande
une étude scientifique au cnrs pour
définir ce qui relève de la recherche et
du militantisme tout cela pour essayer
de voir ce qui relève de l'islamo
gauchisme au sein de l'université votre
votre réaction à cette annonce de la
ministre
écoutez ces jeux c'est un sujet c'est un
sujet complexe et simple parce que en
réalité publié dans le milieu
universitaire mais pas que
des militants politiques qui peuvent
être des professeurs qui peuvent être
des étudiants qui ont une complaisance
envers le mouvement politique des
islamistes
c'est une évidence qui des fois essaye
d'imposer qui a le droit de parler à
l'université aussi mais bon ça on le
connaît il ya des luttes pour les
universités par contre décrire le
phénomène comme un phénomène qui qui
gangrènent l'université cette
exagération et vu là caractérisé par le
caractérisation politique qui n'a rien
de scientifique
elle est allée dire porter des idées
pour porter de l'est le président
d'université lui ont rappelé les choses
à la mini c'est quand même grave que ce
soit les prénoms universités qui
rappelle comment ça se passe à
l'université il ya des commissions des
commissions qui évalue sur le fond des
enseignements qu'il ya des commissions
qui sanctionne canon la fonction
publique quand on dérange ode à la
déroute théologie à l'éthique minimum
que doit avoir un professeur républicain
ça ça existe donc le chien considère qu
ici vous dire quelque chose
elle fait par contre demandé au cnrs qui
est un institut de recherche de faire
une recherche sur l'eau définir et donc
de définir ce qu'on a le droit de penser
pas pensé comment es tu sais quoi
sur une notion qui restent vagues ont pu
sous le paramètre d'évaluation est
compliquée et quelque chose qui vient
est ruiné les efforts de ceux qui se
battent contre des thèses islamistes à
l'université parce que il ya à se battre
et vient à mon avis comme une façon de
botter en touche face au vrai problème
qui a été posée par monsieur ouzoulias
ce qui est que en ce moment à
l'université
le vrai problème c'est la misère et
clientes et qu'il faut il répondre oui
philippe dallier
1 parce que c'est contre productif comme
nous le dit david assouline
et puis c'est vrai qu' on est dans un
moment où les étudiants n'ont même pas
l'université
ils vivent une situation très difficile
et réclament de pouvoir justement et
revenir on s'interroge
j'aurais bien l'opportunité d'une telle
annonce de la voix de la ministre
je pense effectivement je sais pas si le
moment est très bien choisi ceci étant
dit on ne peut pas faire comme si il se
passe est strictement rien à
l'université quand on voit à
l'université c'est quand même un lieu où
on peut débattre a priori et on devrait
pouvoir débattre de tout bien sûr
or de plus en plus un certain nombre de
personnes sont interdites d'expression à
l'université parce que tel syndicat tel
groupuscule s'y opposeront quelques oies
quelques cas il est venu derek écouter
ça ne se reproduise et pas avant ça ne
se fait pas chacun pouvait pas comme ça
se produit maintenant dans l'extrême
droite et légumes ses opinions et on a
rarement vu ou quasiment jamais de
recteur interdire l'organisation de tels
ou tels débats sur tel ou tel sujet
parce que certains s'y opposait deux
voisins quand on regarde moi je dis
qu'il ya un sujet qui est sur la table
et qui doit être regardé quand on voit
également la radicalisation je choisis
le terme
à dessein quand on voit la
radicalisation de certains syndicats
d'étudiants les indigéniste les toutous
ces gens qui effectivement ne supporte
qu'une idéologie la leur et je parle pas
d'islam au gauchissement particulier sur
différents sujets il ya dix ans on est
dans la radicalisation la plus complète
et certains voudraient tout d'un coup
définir ce qu on peut étudier à
l'université les prises de position
qu'on pourra y exprimer c'est la
négation c'est ça c'est ce que c'est la
médiation de ce que devrait être une
vérité dans une grande démocratie comme
un hôte dont qui via un sujet à une
question qui se pose est ce que le
moment est opportun est ce que la
méthode est la bonne on peut en discuter
mais en tous les cas on ne peut pas
faire comme s'il n'y avait pas de dérive
parce que des dérives on a constaté sur
de nombreux sujets et un sujet mérite
pour filmer des business all in mais il
ya des dérives qui est qui qui va le
nier le problème c'est et c'est pour
cela que ces raclées présidents
d'université parle comme ça un ministre
on ne demande pas au cnrs instant
scientifique de venir régler ce qui peut
être de l'ordre de 2 du fonctionnement
normal d'une université avec ses
instances disciplinaires avec son droit
qui doit être appliquée quand il y à des
dérives il faut
agir et vite la ministre est là pour ça
elle fait de la politique
les scientifiques font de la science ils
vont pas définir ce que du point de vue
scientifique
on est en droit de dire c'est à dire
faire une police de la pensée et je
pense que franchement au madame vidal
n'est plus à sa place là elle est face à
une situation lui poser sa démission
pourvoi ne vois je suis pas du genre à
appeler à mais s'il y a une ministre qui
aujourd'hui ne n'est pas sa place au
sens où il ya un vrai besoin de
ministères de l'université parce que
l'université a besoin d'être rassurée
parce que la jeunesse a besoin d'être
rassuré et elle vient juste créé une
polémique de plus je pense que peut-être
c'est ce que disent les présidents
d'université 10 ne peut être de revenir
à l'université savoir ce que c'est que
effectivement le fonctionnement d'une
université elle et frédéric vidal que
l'on a entendues à quelques reprises
lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement tout de
suite rejoindre quand un calme est dans
l'hémicycle du sénat quentin vous avez
suivi pour nous eh bien tous les débats
dans l'hémicycle qu'est ce que vous avez
retenu comme temps fort de cette séance
ans je voulais continuer à parler de
l'université parce qu'au débat sur aude
et audrey du débat sur l'islam au
gauchisme ces mots qui ont été prononcés
par la ministre il a été question de la
situation de la détresse des étudiants
et je voulais vous faire écouter à ce
moment où pierre ouzoulias ce et la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur on
comptait changer un argument elle cela
donc concerner ces étudiants qui ont
faim a dit le sénateur communiste
pourquoi la politique du quoi qu'il en
coûte s'était arrêté à la porte des
campus a dit pierre ouzoulias et écoutez
donc la réponse de frédéric vidal
c'est à dire que les étudiants soient
exclus de la politique du gouvernement
et non et non vraiment pas et d'ailleurs
vous vous voyez peut-être les files
d'attentes mois il se trouve que j'y
vais et que et oui eh bien vous voyez
dans ses fils
dans ces files d'attentes qui font dans
ces files d'attentes qui font selon vous
tellement polémique
qu'est ce que l'on voit et bien on voit
notamment des jeunes
c'est pour ça que nous avons et nous
continuerons à soutenir l'ensemble des
jeunes et les étudiants aient compris
voilà la ministre chahuté par des
sénateurs autant sur les bancs de la
droite comme de la gauche
là le communiste a répliqué avec un
petit trait d'esprit au passage en
l'écoutent veut répondu à aucune de mes
trois questions
peut-être que vous pourriez demander au
cnrs de lancer une enquête sur ce sujet
où l'entendait il a été beaucoup
applaudi pierre aux liens c'est
d'ailleurs que ce soit sur les bancs de
la droite comme ceux de la gauche tam
merci merci beaucoup quand un pource
pour ce résumé de ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure et tout de suite on
continue les réactions celle des
conférences on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard vous êtes avec le sénateur r&d
pays
le groupe de la majorité présidentielle
ici au sénat des hauts-de-seine xavier
iacovelli mais oui on l'a entendu durant
cette séance de questions d'actualité il
ya une crise sociale étudiante
un malaise étudiants xavier iacovelli
est ce que c'est le moment de lancer une
enquête sur ce concept vague
d'islamophobie schisme au sein de
l'université que moi je ne sais pas s'il
ya une dérive peut-être c'est peut-être
mais en tout cas je pense que ce n'est
pas le sujet du moment
moi ce que je vois le sujet du moment
c'est la détresse étudiante ce que je
vois c'est la détresse aussi en termes
de pouvoir d'achat et et moi ce que je
note c'est l'action du gouvernement en
faveur des étudiants qui certes demande
peut-être à être amélioré mais je vois
surtout un million trois cent mille
repas qui a un euro qui ont été
distribués aux étudiants pour les
étudiants c'est quand même un gain de
pouvoir d'achat de quasiment 100 euros
pour les étudiants c'est aussi tout
l'accompagnement qui est et qui est
actuellement mis en place et donc ça
c'est le sujet du moment et je pense que
les enquêtes sur les dérives dans cette
même université
on va peut-être après et justement
pourquoi à ce moment là la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur annonce cette
enquête enfin là il ya un intérêt
politique c'est de surfer sur le terrain
de de l'extrême droite écoutez je ne
pense pas je pense que c'était en
réponse effectivement à une
interrogation du journaliste moi je ne
sais pas pourquoi est-ce que sur ça je
n'aurais pas utilisé déjà ce terme là je
vous cache pas
mais après qu'il ya des dérives
peut-être encore une fois mais je pense
que c'est encore une fois pas le monde
et sur le fond est ce que ça ne vous
pose pas problème de demander à des
scientifiques d'enquêter sur leurs
collègues voilà sur des courants de
pensée est ce que c'est pas une atteinte
à la liberté d'enseignement mais je
pense que le premier ministre l'a répété
le il faut maintenir cette liberté
d'enseignement
le président et le premier ministre sont
très attachés à ça moi le premier et
donc oui effectivement je pense que
c'est pas le bon moment et c'est pas le
bon vecteur
merci beaucoup exagéré pour votre
réaction merci merci beaucoup alexandre
pour cette réaction et puis tout de
suite dedans on va rejoindre à nouveau
quentin parce qu'on voit à parler d'un
autre sujet qui a marqué la séance des
questions d'actualité ce sujet et bien
c'est celui des zones de non contrôle
d'identité puisque en effet qu'en tant
il ya eu quand même trois questions à ce
sujet lors de cette séance tout à
l'heure trois questions sur cèze et une
question posée par chacun des groupes de
droite au sénat chacun des deux groupes
des groupes politiques de droite sur
effectivement cette déclaration de
claret dont la défenseur des droits avec
une proposition un des zones sans
contrôle d'identité un sénateur les
indépendants ainsi parlé pendant la
séance d'une proposition ahurissante
alors la question était la toute
première question sur ce sujet étaient
adressées à gérald darmanin
mais c'est le premier ministre et qui a
tenu à répondre en rappelant que est
bien là défenseur des droits était à la
tête d'une institution indépendante du
gouvernement c'est en effet une à aÿ à
une autorité administrative indépendante
ecoutez jean castex jeudi solennellement
devant le sénat et devant le pays qu'il
n'y a pas et qu'il n'y aura pas de zone
sans contrôle d'identité en application
des lois de là
oui je vous remercie le premier ministre
qui à ce moment là a été
particulièrement applaudie sur les bancs
de la droite et du centre tam merci
merci beaucoup quentin pour ces
nouvelles explications sur la séance
alors la réponse de jean castex elle est
très clair david assouline
la proposition de la défenseur des
droits ne sera pas écouté il n'y aura
pas de ces zones de non contrôle
d'identité oui mais je suis d'accord
avec la réaction des internautes que le
vrai sujet c'est à quoi ils servent ces
contrôles comment ils se sont fait et
qu'est ce qu'on peut bouger dans ce
domaine
or une étude vient de montrer qu'à 95%
ça sert absolument à rien donc claé dont
essayer de formuler une proposition très
maladroite qui veut rien dire parce que
ça ça ça donne l'impression qu'on va
faire des zones de non droit et pas
seulement celles fans inégalités semaine
on habite entassait ça ça n'a pas de
sens à mon avis mais en tous les cas il
faut être aveugle pour ne pas voir que
le contrôle d'identité se fait souvent
au faciès souvent bon j'ai pas envie de
comprendre trop pourquoi
c'est un fait moi mes enfants le raconte
depuis qu ils ont droit de sortir tout
seul le prendre le métro tout seul quand
ils sont avec un ami noirs ou d'origine
arabe
et c est bien il ya contrôle alors que
n'ont jamais subi de contrôle tout ça
jamais bon donc c'est un fait donc
moi non plus je n'ai pas subi ces
contrôles est un acte du disent qu'ils
en ont tous les jours voir une fois par
semaine dans la tête d'un gosse qui le
voit bien que lui les contrôler et pas
son copain parce que c'est sont tous des
copains ils sont dans les mêmes écoles
comment il grandit est ce qu'il se dit
que il est un citoyen français parce que
ce sont des jeunes citoyens de français
comme les autres noms et on crée du
ressentiment
donc ce n'est pas vrai qu'il faut
balayer les propositions on avait nous
proposer un récit dense et on peut
essayer la caméra les mais cette fois-ci
vraiment généraliser et que c'est pas le
policier qui l'a déclenché quand il veut
il
en tout le cas il faut faire des
expérimentations il ya des pays de la
plateforme ont été discriminés pour
essayer de la faune de dire qu'on va
être dans la fermeté républicaine sans
que la promesse républicaine soit la wii
la fermeté républicaine mais toute la
fermeté républicaine c'est à dire qu'on
considère que tous les citoyens français
sont égaux et depuis leur plus jeune âge
là philippe dallier votre votre réaction
il ya eu trois questions de la droite
sur 7 sur ce sujet sur cette
intervention de claire hédon subsistance
des 3/4 un peu reculé rétropédaler sur
l'insertion des questions d'actualité
donc l'actualité enfin je peux
comprendre les réactions des internautes
m'ont fait l'actualité c'était quand
même cette déclaration que je vis
qualifie de saugrenue de la part de
la défenseur des droits franchement qui
pourrait imaginer que dans un territoire
donné imaginé en seine-saint-denis on va
aller dire alors telle ville ou tel
quartier telle ville tout d'un coup il y
aura plus aucun contrôle d'identité mais
franchement mais je me demande parfois à
quoi pensent ce qu'ils peuvent formuler
des propositions comme celle là parce
que si vous voulez moi je viens
intéressé au cas de tout le monde on est
là pour ça mais je pense aussi à ceux
qui sont les victimes première de tout
ce qui effectivement ne respectent pas
les lois de la république
voilà c'est ça une tension après le
ministre a quand même rappeler un
certain nombre de chiffres il ya plus de
5 millions de contrôles qui sont
effectués chaque année
caden 99,7 % des cas il se passe rien il
ya aucun problème ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas des dérives il l'a dit
aussi et il faut essayer effectivement
d'y remédier et de les empêcher et
sociales fiscales et ceci étant dit il
faut j'allais dire garder les bonnes
proportions aux choses
moi je pense que la généralisation des
caméras pour toute interpellation
c'est déjà un très bon point d'entrée
alors ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
ça n'a pas été généralisé faute de
moyens on nous dit que ça va l'être
j'ai envie de dire tant mieux parce que
vous savez quand la caméra si les
policiers ont l'obligation de la
déclencher
je pense que ça change la donne pour
tout le monde parce que tout le monde se
sente en fils mais aussi bien celui qui
est interpellée ou qui est contrôlée que
celui qui contrôle peut se dire bon il
ya des images donc maintenant voilà donc
ça si vous voulez c'est un pas dans la
bonne direction
maintenant le reste et ses zones de
non-droit fait une proposition d'aimer
délirante de mon point de vue je ne
comprends pas que quelqu'un de
respectable par ailleurs comme cette
personne ait pu formuler une proposition
pareille ans elle a rétropédalé le
premier ministre a dit qu'il en était
pas question va fermer la parenthèse et
le débat est clos
sur cette proposition tout les captv des
souliers noirs est énorme et le débat
reste ouvert sur le fou du sujet parce
que justement ce que ça a révélé aussi
c'est que le prg le
les internes ou 10 ou à il ya cinq
millions de dans 99% des cas il n'y a
pas de prix mais ça veut dire que ça
sert à rien aux familles donc ce n'est
pas possible avec quelque chose qui ne
sert à rien de créer une telle
discrimination parce que effectivement
ça trouve que la façon dont le contrôle
se fait vise et socialement et souvent
dans certains quartiers ceux qui n'ont
pas la bonne couleur de la peau et qu'en
plus ça ne protège personne
parce que ce ne sont pas des délinquants
parce que à la fin il n'y a absolument
aucun problème
on a juste embêté et stigmatiser des
jeunes et pas d'autres donc à part ça
moi je suis si c'est comment il ya des
agressions de policiers il faut défendre
un contexte défavorable un nom de gamme
c'est meilhon alors avec toutes les
difficultés que calais par sanou essayer
d'assurer là je suis implacable enfin on
ne peut pas s'attaquer à la police on ne
peut pas agresser les gens ont peut pas
mais justement ces contrôles ne lutte
pas contre ça parce que ces contrôles
montrent que ça ne sert à rien derrière
comment y à pas forcés à rien c'est
incroyable ça parce que 99,7 pour s'en
séparer ce pas serait correctement on
conclut ça ne sert à rien enfin c'est
quand ma mère est la prochaine étape
c'est quoi cette même erreur en disant
il faut les zones de non droit puisque
toute façon les mais les policiers n'ont
pas besoin d'y entrer ça sert à rien ou
alors qu'ils sont drôles de raisonnement
quand il faut il faut il faut contrôler
s'il ya par exemple il y à il ya une
agression ya un attentat on a des on
essaie dans un quartier de trouver on
fait des contrôles mais les faire
systématiquement et au faciès
ça ne sert à rien a creusé le fossé
entre la police et la jeunesse or je
pense que la police sera d'autant plus
efficace pour lutter contre la
délinquance et les trafics qu'elle aura
une relation avec les habitants et
notamment avec la jeunesse qui sera une
relation de confiance aux personnes ne
se sont montrés du doigt les policiers
doivent être respectées les jeunes
doivent être être respectée vous êtes
d'accord là dessus
non mais sur la bière
tout le monde doit respecter tout le
monde très bien dans un département
comme le mien quand on voit la pression
qui pèse sur les policiers
les risques qu'ils prennent tous les
jours les insultes qui les protègent
contre disant qu'il faudrait quand même
relativiser et reconnaître qu'aussi il y
à de grosses difficultés à exercer leur
métier et à protéger tout pour ça dix
mille police alors qu'il n'ya pas
parfois des problèmes mais de là à en
tirer une règle en disant il faut plus
faire de contrôle et des vivres je ne
dis pas il voit l'un faire contrôler
jeudi qu' il faut arrêter avec ça sert à
rien 99% des cas chez parce que ça c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le en scène
basile à 10,6 venir ici non mais écoutez
je vois assez mal débats sémantiques je
pense je pense qu'il faut dénoncer il
faut absolument que l'on puisse faire du
maintien de l'ordre qu' il ya des tâches
très importante et les policiers ne sont
pas suffisants suffisamment nombreux
pour les aides pour pour les assumer et
que peut-être que au lieu de faire du
contrôle systématique à des endroits où
ça ne sert à rien c'est possible on peut
évaluer si ça sert à quelque chose oui
eh bien si ce temps là et consacrer à
d'autres choses peut-être que ça
protégeraient mieux la société et y
compris les policiers se sentiraient
mieux que de faire d'eux des fois
c'était aux chiffres y compris le
contrôle d'identité
merci messieurs pour ce débat et pour
ceux des bribes des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
on va tout de suite prendre la direction
de la salle clémenceau dominique
schnapper sociologue présidente du
conseil des sages de la laïcité est
auditionné par les sénateurs de la
commission des lois dans le cadre de
leurs travaux sur le projet de loi qui
conforte le respect des principes de la
république en janvier 2010